This is Jocko podcast number one 64 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
I crept ahead a few feet and raise carefully to look over the bank crack.
A rifle was thrust up and fired only inches from hails head.
The bullets split his scalp and the concussion broke his ear drums.
Blood streamed over his face,
blinding him,
and I helped get him back to Stewart.
Then I pitched a second bomb close in.
Meanwhile,
Macintyre had not halted.
He had rushed on the and Sam Bro and I have raised as we hurried after him.
A machine gun blazed at us from a spot on the right and we dove into the mud
crash slam.
The stokes gun was at work,
but it's shells dropped short falling almost in our path.
We rose again as the maxim stopped firing.
Then a flaming white hot instant oblivion.
Yeah.
When I recovered consciousness,
my head was splitting with pain and a terrible nausea had seized my stomach.
The Stoke Shell had dropped beside me,
throwing me bodily into the mud and Sam Bro was stunned as well.
He was lying in the slime and feeling his limbs certain that he was wounded all
around us was a frightful clamor of guns and bombs and brightful shots.
I heard Macintyre's voice shouting five rounds rapid.
Then it stopped,
but my nose was bleeding and I was too dizzy to stand.
We crawled towards the sound,
then halted.
There was a great plunging in the MERC and to dim figures came toward us puffing
and blowing,
tugging at something.
They were Germans,
big men and a machine gun and tripod.
They placed it just in front of lesson.
One man gang did along cartridge belt.
I pulled the pin from my last bomb and heaved a missalette account of two.
It burst just beneath the tripod.
One man went down like a huge tree.
The other struggled a moment before he stilled.
We went by them making sure the gun was ruined and in new made crater found in
man of a company with his wrist almost severed.
We bandaged him quickly and send them back and we're rising to go on.
When Clark came stumbling through the mud and yelled at us,
come on,
give them
his shout was cut off.
He pitched dead in front of us.
The man scurried by with a stretcher and we went over to the bank where we could
see men moving.
It was Louis Gunner and he said Macintyre had been shot through the stomach and
was dying.
Okay.
They got him on the old stretcher,
but he went on the to the shore bank in front and found old Bill Mickey and
Johnson Crouch.
They're shooting at a German gun with that streak.
Sparks not more than 30 yards away.
Sam Bro had bombs with him and he and I hurled them.
The burst seems right.
It seemed right on the gun and it was silenced.
I stared at the other men on the bank.
Yeah,
they were all dead.
Melville and IRA and Jennings lying there together,
rifle in hand,
all shot through the head by one sweep of the German gun.
Old Bill had seen it and stayed thereafter trying to pop the gunner himself
before dead man was poor.
Old Sam at rest.
At last
we looked around and found all the rest of the party.
He'd gone,
but another fit of sickness seized me and I could not move for a long time.
Sam Bro stayed with me.
We did not go back.
We had to crawl a distance to avoid the machine gun fire,
but the main fighting had shifted over to the left.
A light vapor was stealing over the ground,
making it harder to see and I stumbled over a body as we found the road bank.
It was the professor riddled with bullets dead.
He was covered with mud,
had lost his steel helmet,
had evidently got lost in the darkness.
And there he lay after years of study and culture with Glassy eyes and face up
term to the sky,
a smashed cog of the war machine with not a hope of burial accepting by a chance
shell and the mist thickened enrolled suddenly over him.
Knight found us,
still crouched in our cover and I got up and went around the shell holes until I
found old bill and Johnson.
They told me that a relief was due and that there had been no orders.
Okay.
Then a corporal from another platoon came and called to us to follow him.
We were to go back to [inaudible].
The 16th battalion was relieving us.
We went and met the incoming men by our old trench where we're joined by the
remainder of the company and heard that big Glen had been killed.
That is,
he died gloriously in the fighting at the graph house.
All that long dragged back was a hideous nightmare.
Yeah.
The track was worse than when we had come and in the shelling was insistent
incessant.
We moved with infinite slowness.
Every step,
a struggle,
uh,
tearing physical effort and a vast noise was all thundering,
rolling clamor that doled our thinking,
mercifully some smothering.
Some of our agonized impressions of that night before
the November rains.
We're chilling,
US freezing us.
Our feet were always soggy and we were almost despondent.
Okay.
All that time we'd been out,
we had talked,
but little each man seemed busy with his own thoughts,
disinclined to speak to one another.
There had been to many of our friends killed the men we had been with for
months.
I've found that Mcleod and farmer had in the mud.
Egglestone had been wounded in placed on a stretcher and then he and his bearers
were all blown to fragments by a big shell and portaled.
Flynn had been killed.
We seem to move in a days to do things as if we were automatons.
When it grew dark,
we moved again to form a new line.
The Hun spotted us and started shelling wall machine gun fire,
rake the ground up.
Him and I were together.
As we started digging,
I saw body just in front of us.
A big man with his equipment over is great coat catch,
hold of that stiff.
I said to Upham,
pull him back here and we'll use them for part of our parapet.
He stared at me,
don't he yelled,
don't touch him.
I seized the corpse myself,
rolling it over into place and up sprang from where he had been spading and
commenced on new hole over to the right.
A salvo of shells came and exploded.
Whizzing fragments were all around me,
but I was not touched
up and fell and was dead when I reached him.
There was a strange cry further on.
It was the sergeant major who should have gone to the depot,
the old original he and insisted and coming in for one more trip and his jaw had
been carried away by shrapnel.
He died before morning
two other men were down.
Johnson and baron both wounded.
The shelling continued all that night and the next day,
yeah,
we had dug deep v shaped pits,
connecting some of them and there we crouched gray faces under muddy helmets,
red rimmed eyes,
staring dazed,
wondering our brains numbed beyond thinking by the incessant explosions.
One of the new men pitch down between our shelter and the next one he was
pierced in a dozen places and one arm had been sheered from his body by
shrapnel.
Mickey sat beside me shuttering,
half stoned,
staring unseeing,
his limbs twitching convulsively at each concussion.
And that right there is a couple of pages
worth of reading of the book and we go on written by a guy by the name of wheel
bird who was a Canadian soldier that fought in world war one.
And like I said,
that's just a couple of pages from the book.
But the pages go on and on and on just like that war did.
And you,
you explain it like the amount of people killed around him,
a wounded around him.
It's,
it's horrific and it's hard to
even fathom what that did to these men before,
during,
and after combat physically and mentally and psychologically
and the physical part.
These are things that you can see,
you can see those wounds,
you can understand them,
but the psychological part is perhaps
okay,
the hardest to understand.
Okay.
Now I say that this podcast is about human nature and the reason it is,
and the reason that I focus on human nature is because in my opinion,
in order to lead people,
you have to understand people.
You have to understand what their nature is.
You have to understand human nature and
okay.
A lot of human nature boils down to psychology.
And I recently got a recommendation from,
uh,
trooper out on the interwebs who recommended a book called psychology for the
fighting man.
And this is a book that was first printed in 1943 and the book is,
it's an incredible book.
It's filled with an immense amount of very useful information and it's written
as almost like a mental guide to the American military men that are getting
ready to go fight the Germans and the Japanese in World War II,
obviously 1943 that's when it's written.
This is right in the middle of World War II and even though the book is 75 years
old,
the,
the information that's in it,
the knowledge that is contained inside of it,
okay
can still be utilized today in any leadership situation.
And in fact,
this book is so dense with information that I'm actually going to split it into
two separate podcasts so that we can go into some more detail and not end up
with a 14 hour podcast.
So
let's kick it off.
Going into this book.
As I said,
the title of the book is psychology for the fighting man.
And the subtitle is what you should know about yourself and others
kicks off part one a psychology and combat.
When the British eighth army pursued the retreating axis forces from Egypt
through Libya,
they found a long root grow.
They found along the route great quantities of abandoned equipment,
some tanks,
guns in perfect condition and gasoline for the tanks and ammunition for the
guns.
The physical materiel of a large access force was there,
but it was useless to the access.
There were no men left to operate it.
You keep hearing it said that men cannot fight without weapons,
but it is just a true that weapons cannot fight without men.
And Army is men.
Not any men at all.
For a crowd of men may only be a mob,
but trained and equipped men.
What sort of equipment do men have?
An army need?
Planes,
tanks,
guns and jeeps.
Mortars,
grenades,
rifles.
And bayonets camouflaging mess kits above all food and water.
Everything that the ordinance and quartermaster can supply.
But that is not all.
No.
The men need morale.
They need courage.
They must have confidence in each other.
And the belief in ultimate victory,
who is the quarter master?
Who can issue stocks of courage and confidence?
Yet these are essential weapons.
So we started off with a great point.
Where do you get your courage issued?
Not from the quartermaster,
not from the supply guy.
No.
It's got to come from somewhere else and it is just as important part of winning
a war as tanks,
planes,
bullets and bombs going on and the army must have leaders to plenty of them cos
and NCS who supplies them.
Besides leaders,
it must have all sorts of special abilities and skills,
mechanical,
mechanical ability and in particular is needed in this new mechanized war.
Ability to drive trucks,
pilot ability,
mathematical ability,
cooking ability,
clerk skills,
lots and lots of abilities.
You can't fight a war without them and the army needs efficiency too.
And efficiency means not only effective organization.
There's also basic efficiency of the individual man,
his strength and health,
his resistance to hardship and fatigue,
his alertness even when fatigued and despite freezing cold or exhausting heat
toughness of body is a weapon,
indispensable to victory.
This book is so straightforward.
It's just so straightforward and it doesn't pull any punches.
It's,
it's one of the best things about this and you can tell it's written,
it's directed,
it's directed for like the frontline grunt trooper.
That's who it's directed at and not just the infantry guy,
but anybody in the army doing any job.
And it's refreshing to read something that's as straightforward as this book is
going on.
The army has a perpetual problem of psychological logistics,
a problem of the supply of motives and of aptitudes and abilities of habits and
wisdom.
How does it get this mental materiel to the right places at the right time?
That is what this book is about.
So again,
it's looking at the psychological aspect of warfare and saying,
how do you,
how do you deliver these necessary supplies?
We need courage,
right?
We need abilities,
we need emotions,
we need aptitudes,
we need the right habits.
How do you deliver those
back to the book if the army cannot find a man with needed ability,
an effort is made to find one with an aptitude for being trained in that
ability.
And then it trains them all in part by teaching them the rules and the
techniques in part by giving them practice.
No troops are ready to go into combat until their training period is over and
even then they are still green troops.
The training is still going on in combat until finally the men are seasoned
troops have learned how to meet the unexpected emergencies of war and have
acquired that competence and confidence.
That is the basis of their courage.
Okay?
It is this human materiel that determines more than any other one thing,
whether an army will win or lose.
Guns and chow are essential to but given equally of supply victory goes to the
better troops,
troops composed of men who know their jobs and do them willingly and well men
with initiative to act by themselves,
the train troops which make up the season to army.
Okay?
There are moreover fundamental differences between people that affect their ways
of fighting and their abilities to fight.
These differences are not,
however,
due to blood as the Nazis teach,
but mostly due to training,
tradition,
home life,
and other things that have a powerful effect on the character of men.
War is waged best by choosing methods of warfare best adapted to the nature of
our own people and opposed to the natures of the enemy.
Peoples.
American men have no particular love for killing.
Yeah,
for the most part,
they hate killing.
They think it is wrong.
Sinful ordinarily punishable by death.
They do not look upon death as a beautiful and glorious experience and most of
them do not consider the military life as a suitable life.
Work War Two American men is a dirty,
disagreeable business to be gotten over as soon as possible so that we as a
nation can get along with what we were happily engrossed in inventing,
producing,
growing,
making life more useful and satisfying.
Americans can stand a long,
hard pull.
They look forward not back.
They are slow to accept.
War will not go all out until they are attacked or are sure their ideals are in
grave danger.
But once they have started,
they do not stop or spare themselves until the goal of victory seems to them to
be secure.
Perhaps in 1919 they made a mistake about having already made the world safe for
democracy,
but they would not have stopped had they thought,
had they not thought themselves safe,
nor will they stop.
Now
they are not demoralized by temporary adversity or single defeats.
So some good info,
right?
They're clearly trying to set the mental attitude of the American young American
soldiers that are reading this.
We can stand the long hard pull.
If you mess with us,
we're going to finish it.
We're not demoralized by temporary adversity or single defeats doesn't matter
you.
You want a battle right on.
Watch this.
We'll be back.
Continuing on,
it has been said that war is inevitable,
that men are so made that they just have to fight.
That is true.
If you mean they have to be aggressive,
that they need to have power and to use it,
that they are forever wanting to change things that are hard to change,
so as that they can get on with better living.
But the fact is that they do not have to fight each other and not many Americans
agree with Hitler in thinking,
fighting other nations a good thing for any nation,
even when the ugly,
ugly business ends in victory,
there are other things than men and nations to fight.
Yeah,
men can fight calamity and disaster,
flood,
fire and famine with anger and zest and even fight nature to prevent disasters
happening.
They fight disease.
Having for a century been waging effective war upon it with a numerable
conquest,
which history now records.
They fight for freedom,
freedom to worship as they wish,
freedom to think and speak as they please.
Freedom from want and poverty.
Freedom from fear.
That's the American and democratic philosophy.
The reason why America is now at war,
every American ought to understand this.
To know why a nation that wants peace has to go to war
because nobody likes murder.
You have to kill the murderers.
You cannot get along without police.
And this war is a policing job.
It's a large scale job because it is a total war.
So clearly this book is,
is answering a lot of questions for an 18 year old kid that's heading out to
warn,
maybe doesn't fully understand why or what's happening and here it is,
just laying it out.
Look,
these people are bad.
We're good.
They need where the police of the world,
which sometimes in the,
in,
in today's time,
people take that as a negative,
like we can't be the world police,
but here he's straight up.
This is straight up saying,
yes,
we are the world police.
There's bad guys.
We're going to go put them down.
And it's interesting too.
Nobody likes murder.
You have to kill murders.
That's the way it's got to be.
Again,
you know,
these days we get so desensitized to buy media right by movies and video games
and music talking about killing,
and that's just,
that's the way we grow up.
But in the in these days,
you had to kind of convince people that,
hey,
this is the way it's going to go down.
You're going to go kill people.
And that's okay.
Total war is just what its name implies.
War On all fronts with all possible weapons.
There's the home front as well as all the battlefronts there.
Also the military front,
the economic front and the psychological front,
military economic and psychological warfare,
makeup,
total war.
The Germans had that big idea first,
but the Americans can fight the devil with his own fire and a hotter one and are
doing it.
The three kinds of warfare all related a military success may also be an
economic victory if it results in the capture of great quantities of enemy
materiel or blocks.
Important supply routes to the enemy nation or it can be a psychological victory
if it lowers enemy morale,
helps to make soldiers expect to feed leads the enemy people to be ready to
submit.
What I like about this idea of total war is when you apply it to other parts of
your life,
right?
If you apply it to business and how you can't just focus on one aspect of
business,
you can't just focus on,
hey,
we're going to go out and create something new.
Guess what?
We get to create something new.
We got to sell it.
We've got to figure out the way to get the cost to produce down.
We've got to figure out how we're going to beat our competitors.
We've got to figure out how we're going to spray.
You've got to figure out all these things.
Total war in business,
in life,
total war,
right?
How do you win?
The total year?
Life is war,
right?
Your life is a war.
You're fighting against all these things that are happening and you're fighting
to win.
You're fighting to be healthy.
You're fighting to be financially stable.
You're fighting to take care of your family in the best possible way.
It's total war and all these things.
You have to fight all of these fronts at the same time all the time.
That's why you can't sleep at night because it's total Warren life.
Yeah,
that's so true.
It's like you can,
you can be like winning certain battles in life.
You know,
like you can have a great job making great money,
but don't exercise and be poor health,
you know,
or,
or opposite or what.
There's so many like just as battles,
you know?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And you have to be paying attention to those.
You have to pay attention to all the fronts.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of times where people get focused on one front.
And it just doesn't,
it doesn't help.
And even even like inside of a business,
you'll get a business where they just focus on one thing and they'll miss it.
They're getting flanked.
Yeah.
Big Time.
A lot of those times in this goes in life obviously.
That's what,
how I'm thinking of it.
But uh,
yeah.
And like in companies,
right,
where you say they focus so much on one thing and then a lot of times is because
that thing is like has a big payoff,
you know,
like you get,
it seems like,
Dang,
I'm getting ahead.
Huge Times.
Especially like at like at home,
right.
Where,
let me just put it in just a few more hours of work.
Right.
A week for a month,
two months,
three months,
and Dang,
that paycheck comes in and you do sold well for the com.
You go to work,
you're the hero kind of thing and you're like,
Dang,
I'm getting ahead.
Big Time,
but like something else,
we'll kind of falter,
which won't show itself right away,
you know?
Then when you like how you seek it,
flank flanked,
you're like,
Dang,
I hope just flank you.
You got to get focused on all fronts.
Continuing on an economic success of our own can lead to a military defeat of
the enemy.
If it robs him of essential supplies,
it can become a psychological victory if it disheartens him and makes him
readier to give in.
On the other hand,
of course,
a military victory is useless if it leads to a psychological defeat.
The Japanese may have done a great,
may have done great military damage at Pearl Harbor,
but it resulted in net loss to them because of the effect of uniting the
Americans in anger.
Real defeats other than deaf are psychological in the end.
That's pretty powerful.
Real defeats other than death itself or just psychological,
right,
so they're just psychological.
The enemy gives up surrenders.
You have to kill the enemy or make him surrender.
There isn't any other kind of victory.
If he is fanatical,
you may just have to kill him.
Americans would rather just get them to surrender.
So this is something that's so important to remember is that if you get beat,
it's psychological.
If you're still alive,
it's just a psychological defeat.
You just need to reframe it and how are you going to come back and win next
time?
Psychological warfare is the newest arm in war.
It is directed at opinion,
belief,
confidence,
courage,
and the will to fight.
It is both defensive and offensive for it tries to build up morale in our people
and troops and to break down the morale of the enemy.
The chief weapon of psychological warfare is propaganda.
The radio and the press are used to bolster on the home front.
The enemy has reached by newspapers and leaflets dropped from airplanes and by
short wave radio propaganda.
In spite of what many people think is not necessarily dishonest.
Truth is often the best propaganda,
especially when it is fed to persons who are starving for it.
The most effective propaganda must be founded on fact must start from some
important event that actually happened and is known to be true.
Then the propagandist interprets the event.
Much as a good lawyer interprets evidence in favor of his client or as the
honest advertiser makes a claim for his product.
This is another very important part.
When you're in a leadership position,
how much of being leader is making sure that the propaganda it gets out there?
Have you ever heard this expression when someone says,
uh,
you know,
you're not really good at telling your story if you ever heard that before,
like a,
like a company there,
they're out there trying to do great things and they are,
they're working harder,
they're having some success,
but nobody knows it.
And I've,
when I work with companies,
there's sometimes the companies,
no one even inside the companies knows about the successes that they're having.
They're failing to even spread the word within their own company.
And so they think they're getting crushed by the,
by the competitors.
Because they're not,
because the competitors,
guess what?
The competitor's great at propaganda.
Every time the,
that,
the,
uh,
competitors signs a new client,
they put out a big linkedin post,
right?
They put in a big social media blast,
Hey,
wait,
just the sign.
I know it's great to welcome up our and our newest client.
Meanwhile,
you know,
a company's not doing that.
So everyone inside the company doesn't know that we're signing all these new
clients.
So this idea of propaganda is,
is very important in warfare and in leadership and in business.
And at the same time you might've heard about this,
I probably have,
you know,
he was Facebook,
maybe Instagram,
I forget,
but they did like some study where it like,
it actually was linked to people getting depressed because of that.
And it's this,
this con,
that concept that you just said,
well,
you know people,
and this is nothing new.
Where,
where people,
they'll post just their highlights of their life and then like me as just a
normal person and I'm looking at everyone else's highlights of their life.
Think,
Dang,
I don't live that kind of life.
I'm not traveling to Thailand and you know,
all these places,
and maybe I do,
but that was like once last year and this,
you know,
it seems so it kind of that it's,
it's like propaganda maybe on purpose,
maybe not,
but it's like,
yeah,
it's like the perception,
you know,
where you have,
you,
you know your life and it's like the highlights are like one out of a thousand.
Meanwhile,
everyone seemingly is
one out of one.
Just all highlights another Sushi restaurant tonight with a bunch of girls and a
Lamborghini,
all that stuff,
man.
And it's like everyone except me,
you know?
So it's kind of that feeling Echo Charles,
he's not
whatever,
I'm not gonna fall for it.
I'm not going to fall off.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
It's true.
And that stuff does,
it does build up.
It does.
And that's like propaganda in your own life.
Now,
believe you,
I'm not recommending that you do good propaganda of your ids to grab to showed
your positive life.
No,
no,
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying don't believe the hype military psychology is psychological warfare
is not.
However,
the only way which psychology contributes to success in combat,
there are hundreds of others and soldiers and officers need to know what
psychologists know and what psychological methods can find out.
For instance,
soldiers need to understand men in order to understand themselves and their
comrades and officers must learn how to interpret an influence,
the conduct of those for whom they are responsible.
So this is exactly what I say,
old time.
If you want to be a good leader,
you got to understand people.
The soldier must know about human needs,
motives,
and emotions about fear when it comes,
what to do about it,
about anger,
when it is useful,
when it makes trouble about zest,
which is the core of good morale in a unit about anxiety and the sense of
insecurity,
about indignation against the enemy,
any irritation against comrades about the relation of food and have sex to
military life.
He should know also of the relation of all these things to morale and thus learn
how to avoid bad morale and to build up good morale
clearly.
And this is not just true for combat,
this is true for life.
Every soldier ought to understand further the problems of the mental adjustment
of men first to the army later to combat why men feel insecure.
What makes for courage?
The signs of approaching breakdown,
how to prevent breakdown and what to do about it when it happens.
The selection and training of leaders for the army has become one of the most
important problems in the cycle in the psychology of war.
Not Enough is known about it,
but what is known to some should be known to.
All the good leader is the man who builds up morale.
How does he do it?
What kind of man must he be if he is a poor leader,
can he become a better one?
And there are mobs and panics to be understood to civilian mobs and panics may
be the concern of the soldier when the populous gets mixed up with a fighting or
when the enemy's homefront begins to break.
Panics may moreover occur in well-disciplined troops.
If all the conditions for panic are present.
What are these conditions?
Why are seasoned troops panicked less than green troops?
The army place each man with his talents where he will be used to his best
advantage,
but each individual must know how to get the most out of his talents.
The primitive fact of combat is that man pushes when he encounters an obstacle
to the achievement of his desire,
pushes more if blocked,
gets angry of still forwarded and then fights,
but to this fighting,
he eventually brings all of the knowledge and skill that has made him supreme
among the animals.
He fights by learning how to use his eyes at night and learning how to arrange a
system that will let him hear inside of an airplane.
He fights by selecting good leaders and good truck drivers.
He fights by understanding human nature in order to build up good morale that
will overcome fear.
He fights by saying the right thing in the right way to the right people at the
right time and sometimes that is propaganda.
He uses every resource of science and intelligence,
including psychology.
He has two,
four this is total war
I love.
They get about that,
about every aspect of your life is to be prepared for total war.
Which by the way,
you're in,
you know,
you might not be in combat at this moment in time,
but you're fighting,
you're fighting all the time and you have to bring every asset,
every resource that you have available.
You have to bring it to fight cause this is total war.
Now the book goes into some pretty big sections right here.
One of them cite is a weapon or site as a weapon and then and then hearing as a
tool and it literally talks about how to see better things you can do to make
your night vision better,
how to preserve your night vision,
how to c sharp or just all those kinds of things.
He talks about camouflage and stuff.
Real tactical stuff.
And then it talks about hearing and what you need to hear and how you can adjust
your hearing and how to listen sharply.
And I'm gonna go,
I'm not going to talk about the site piece,
but I'm going to talk about the noise.
There's just some interesting points about noise.
Loud sounds,
especially when they are sudden in strange our natural causes of fear.
Many sounds are terrifying.
A sudden loud noise like the discharge of a pistol will make anyone blink and
jump it.
We'll start with a limb.
This is true even well trained men who pride themselves on their familiarity
with firearms.
It is an instantaneous response that may be all over before the,
I can see it.
It shows up.
However,
in slow motion pictures seasoned troops get so that they don't appear to pay any
particular attention to the din of battle.
Even horses will stand still under the rising roar of a diving bomber will only
toss a head impatiently.
The experience soldier on the other hand needs first to become adapted to the
noises of war.
He must be exposed to them in training as much as possible.
After the noise is become familiar,
it's loudness will not affect him so greatly in combat.
Control over noise makes it less fearful.
You don't mind the noise of gunfire so much as you are the one who is doing the
shooting.
So talking about brick,
getting people used to the,
the loud noises that you're gonna come up against.
And this is something that we used to do.
I don't even know if guys do it anymore cause it's probably not that smart.
But we used to do immediate action drills with no ear protection in.
So we'd get used to shooting guns and having all that just massively loud noise.
And we wouldn't do it every time.
But we would do several rounds with no ear protection.
This is
now in current times.
Guys have these nice headsets that have noise,
they're noise canceling headsets.
So they're actually pretty awesome.
So it's not that big of a deal anymore.
But back in the day,
they wanted to make sure,
hey,
you gotta realize how loud this is going to be if you get in a firefight,
if you get your first firefight and you've never had a,
an [inaudible] machine gun two feet away from your ear,
get getting crazy laid down,
a hundred round belts,
it'll be a shock to your system.
So that's what,
and,
and not to mention they're hucking grenades,
simulators at you and in artillery simulators.
So there's explosions going off cause that's what,
that's what they're trying to do.
Get you used to that scenario.
No
men subjected to the excessive noise of war over a long period.
Sometimes it build up an over sensitiveness to any sort of loud sharp report.
Okay.
They are in the state of a man with a hangover.
The Bang of a door will make them jump.
A loud shout is painful.
The noise of a truck exhaust is frightening in the hospitals where men are
convalescing from bad cases of these war nerves.
The dropping of a Pan will startle a ward full of sleeping men so violently that
the jerk,
we'll bring them out of their sleep and even out of their beds and onto the
floor.
But this state of nerves,
the linked in their minds with the noise and produced by the noise is due mainly
to more disturbing things that have become associated with the noise.
Noise is just as loud and originally just as distressing as the noises of war.
If they are only just a part of everyday work or fund tolerated,
men become used to the din of a boiler factory or a pneumatic drill.
It may deafened them,
but it does not demoralize them.
So that's pretty obvious,
right?
What's,
what's making these noises horrible to use?
Cause every time a bomb goes off you see your friends get blown up and killed
and you're afraid that the same thing's going to happen to you.
Whereas a pneumatic drill just making a bunch of noise or you're not that
worried about it.
This was,
again,
there's a lot of real basic information.
You can imagine this book being issued to frontline troops,
but I had to call this one out here to sooner or later most soldiers have the
experience of getting lost in heavy words are jumbled as possibly get lost a few
yards,
just a few yards off the trail.
It gives a man a peculiar helpless feeling.
You are so accustom all your life to knowing where you are and who you are and
about what time it is that the feeling of not knowing what of these things comes
as a great shock.
And then it goes on a little from the,
it says a compass is a big help and I was like,
hmm,
yeah,
yes it is indeed.
There's another real captain,
obvious it is best to have a map in your pocket when you get lost.
If you can't have one,
then you ought to see one before you get into strange country.
So that's real obvious to the Mora soldier knows about maps,
better equip,
he is for combat duty is training and how to read them and what to look for on
them if he keeps practicing,
should enable him to find himself.
If he ever gets lost on any terrain,
he knows from map and the reason I called that part out is think about all the
situations that you get in where you have the opportunity to gather some
intelligence before you go into them.
You know,
if you're going for a job interview,
what can you do about that company?
If you're going to meet with a client you've never met with before,
how much information can you have with these days?
You can Google,
so when you get all kinds of information,
you go to their linkedin account,
you can find out where they went to school and what sport they play it or
whatever.
You go to their Facebook page,
you go to their give,
pull up articles that were written about them,
and there's all kinds of intelligence you can gather.
There's no reason to go into a meeting blind anymore without knowing the terrain
that you're getting into without understanding the culture that you're going
into.
There's no reason for it.
Next work in the army as much more than just shouldering a rifle and doing long
foot marches.
Soldiers work at several hundred different kinds of fighting jobs and add even
more kinds of jobs,
some directly related to combat in some not which can be filled with men already
trained for them or men who have the necessary aptitude for learning.
One of the jobs quickly.
All leaders have the responsibility for seeing that the right man gets the right
job.
And when mistakes are made,
that misfits are transferred.
And this thing is this where this book gets pretty politically incorrect.
It's basically,
look,
some people can't do this jobs.
Some people aren't fit for these jobs and some people aren't fit for these other
jobs.
Hmm.
Continuing on thousands know how to drive a tractor,
how to repair an ignition system.
Others can weld castings,
repair watches,
other timing instruments or road transits.
Keep accounts,
carve carcasses of beef,
develop photographs.
The army needs many men who can do these things.
The British found that out in the first world war.
At first,
they neglected to save their specialists.
They sent to the front professional men,
engineers and men and skilled trades.
Many were killed in the early months of the war.
Later,
the need for them in special posts behind the line became a cute.
So,
yeah,
this is all about forming up an army of civilians that have skills and saying,
oh,
you've been a truck driver for whatever for six years in the civilian sector.
Guess what you're going to do for us?
You're going to drive a truck.
Oh,
you're a butcher.
Guess what?
We need butchers and right on down the line,
and you can imagine world war one,
probably them.
That being very shortsighted.
It'll how long that Warren was going to last him like,
oh,
you're a mechanic.
Cool.
We're just going to send you the front with everyone else and you're going to
die like everyone else,
and you look up in six months or a year and they don't have the necessary
support logistically to carry on the war.
Hmm.
How soldiers differ?
Men differ just as much.
Inability to learn different sorts of duties as they do in size of feet in
height or in weight.
Some are as much as three times as able as others.
I like that.
Hey,
some people are just three times more capable than you.
That's the way it is.
Most of course are just about average.
Some men cannot learn a three,
a three figure telephone number by hearing it once some can learn as many as
nine figures.
The average is around six or seven.
Have you ever heard that before?
Have you ever heard that the reason our numbers are seven digits long is cause
that's about the average that a human can memorize.
No,
I haven't and that's very interesting.
I heard that it could that possibly be
not bro Science,
but uh,
urban myth.
Could it be an urban legend?
It could be.
It's true.
I like it.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Actually.
Will you,
will you have your doctorate in Bro Science?
So I'm working on it.
Yes.
You did.
You do your Undergrad in,
uh,
urban legend.
Uh,
back to the book.
Some men starting from scratch can learn in eight weeks to receive and send
radio code at 16 words per minute.
It takes others 22 weeks.
Some men used to handling certain types of machinery can learn to handle certain
kinds of weapons much faster than others.
So the problem is to understand and measure aptitude.
Aptitude is potential skill.
The capacity for learning to do something quickly and accurately when given the
chance to learn.
Both speed and accuracy are important in learning.
A soldier needs to learn rapidly,
but also to be accurate at what he's learned and men different differ from one
to another in both ways.
For one thing,
men differ greatly in the speed with which they learned.
Some aviation cadets can solo solo after four hours of instruction.
Others are not allowed to so low,
even after 14 hours.
Here,
the quick learners are urgently needed.
Slow learners tie up the training fate planes too long besides quick learning
might mean a shorter warm,
yet the armory cannot do without the slow learners.
Manpower is needed and there are many military jobs which require other
qualities than speed of learning jobs,
which the slow learners will prefer to have.
Men also differ in speed and accuracy of reaction.
The average driver requires from one half to three quarters of a second to put
on the brakes after the stop light goes red.
Yet some can apply the brakes in three tenths of a second.
Others use up to a whole second.
These are important differences for riflemen and machine gunners as well as for
truck drivers.
Every 10th of a second counts in battle.
They were see that thing when they were um,
they would do in like the speed tests for Conor McGregor.
Then he was the,
he was the fastest athlete.
They had tested speed,
like reaction kind of like reaction time.
Like when you see something you touch a button or whatever,
you know,
whatever.
They have these little tests set up.
Then apparently Mcgregor was the fastest athlete that they had tested,
which is crazy.
Yeah,
it is crazy.
It is crazy.
Cause you know some of these baseball players and I guess I think,
I think that would be the,
do you think that would be the fastest Hyandai coordination?
I don't tell them my head seems like it.
I mean cause those balls come quick.
Yeah.
There is a test that you can do when we're kids wa how they do in science class.
You hold one guy,
you know,
they,
you get a ruler.
Oh yeah.
And then drop it.
Yeah.
The teacher holds it and then you put it,
he puts it on your finger,
you know,
between your fingers.
Right at the,
at the zero mark he dropped it and how quick you can.
How far do your fingers have to be opened?
I don't know cause it seems like that could be an advantage.
My grandfather used to do this,
well it's called the dollar drop.
Okay.
And he would fold a dollar lengthwise only to make it kind of aerodynamic.
If you could catch the dollar,
you could,
you could keep it.
Okay.
It sounds pretty easy.
It,
yes sir.
It
does.
Some people can't catch that dollar.
Yeah.
So you think if you're,
you know,
uh,
you know how you're saying,
you just said how far your fingers.
Yeah.
The thing is for the experiment,
as long as you designate kind of that,
you know,
or even eyeball it,
I mean it might be a millimeter difference,
but you know,
usually it's like there's always those people that are looking for that edge.
Right.
Is Jocko.
Yes.
Because I'm thinking I would be figuring out how,
cause I used to do that with a dollar drop.
Right.
I'd get my fingers here.
Yes.
That makes sense.
When the,
you know,
the dog has more stakes for sure.
Pulls out that
you're really the guy in science class who wanted to win though,
even though it wasn't a competition.
Of course it's a competition.
So in,
I don't know,
I'm pretty sure that that stuff can be trained as well.
And that's one thing that um,
you know,
we,
when you're bringing your kids up,
you bring them up and you make them play multiple different sports.
You don't feel cause some too young because they become,
they don't,
they don't develop the broader athletic skills.
So you're supposed to get them involved in a bunch of different sports and those
kids will end up,
even if he took one kid and you say,
oh,
did you just going to do a hundred percent football his whole life?
And you took another kid and you did multiple sports and but you did like a
little bit more of a focus on football.
The chances are they kid that did multiple sports but focused on football is
going to do better than the kid that just did football.
From what I understand,
I'm sure there's some bro Science people out there that will uh,
object to my statement.
Oh it makes sense.
You know where it's brought more broadly athletic and pre,
I'd imagine you'd be able to learn quicker too because your body is used to
moving different ways rather than just a one way.
What are you going to do with things are a little bit different out on the
football field,
right?
Cause little situations that can unfold it if you're athletically adept at
adapting to various situations are going to be better off.
Yeah,
it's true.
Going on,
men differ also in the speed and accuracy of perceiving.
One clerk can check in five minutes accompany roster.
That takes another man 20 minutes.
Some men can see a white target in the dark at 400 yards away to others.
It is invisible.
At 200 yards rangefinders differ in their ability to tell the distances of
different objects when the job is seeing you must choose the best seniors.
So That's interesting cause you could have someone that has bad reactions but to
see really well and if you ever read,
I'm sure at some point we'll do chuck Yeager's book can hear back from matter of
fact,
chuck Yeager's on Twitter,
I don't know if you know that,
but chuck Yeager's on Twitter and I've gone back and forth a couple times.
People have said come on the podcast,
but in his podcast or his book Yeager,
he just had incredible vision.
Like he'd be flying in formation and he could see the enemy way before anyone
else could see the enemy.
He'd be like up bogeys at four o'clock,
boom,
we go.
And because his eyesight was apparently just amazing,
that used to be a big deal for fighter pilots.
I think it's less of a big deal now because you got radar and all that.
So it's not as big of a deal as it used to be.
Just your eyes against the enemy's eyes.
Back to the book.
There is however much more to a good soldier than speed and accuracy with which
he learns acts and perceives every man has interests,
likes and dislikes.
These determined in part what he will do well and how fast he will improve a
man's interest.
For instance,
for instance,
usually determine what he will do with what he learns.
Mere exposure to training never made a skilled soldier.
It is the interested man who remembers and profits by his training and is ready
to apply it to new situations.
Right?
So it's so true how true.
It's just so true.
So true.
We don't,
and what I think is really important about this from a business perspective is
what they're basically saying is put the right people in the right jobs.
That's the overall concept of put the right people in the right jobs.
That's what you need to do.
If you've got someone that might not be super talented,
but they're very interested,
they're probably the better higher than someone that's just got a bunch of town
but doesn't care.
In fact,
I'll go ahead and say they straight up are the better.
Higher.
Yeah.
Cause it,
and then they'll,
they'll wind up learning like so quick.
And your specific thing,
you know,
you're specifically,
they're into it.
If someone is not into it,
that's,
that's bad.
Oh,
like someone who has like a major like degree and you know,
his resumes,
he honored degree but like,
Hey,
I'm really into whatever it is that you're doing.
Like for instance,
you like making videos,
gear into it,
right?
Sure.
If you didn't like,
you know,
if you got no enjoyment from it,
think of how horrible it would be
to trying to get you to do it.
I mean,
it's pretty hard to get you to do video right now and you're actually like doing
it.
Yeah.
Or you know,
like,
um,
like politics.
Right.
You know how like some people they like politics,
some people don't.
So you get someone who likes politics and the news comes on,
they're going to be all up in there learning everything.
What's going on like today,
you know,
then someone who's not there,
like all the news is on.
Let me watch.
Well that's an interesting,
I thought you were going to say that people that are in DePaul,
because I actually have,
that's one case where I would disagree because a lot of times people that really
like politics,
you don't want them in politics because they're just political machines.
Right?
You want a normal person.
Oh yeah.
He's just a normal everyday.
You don't want the person that's like,
you know what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna be precedent.
I'm going to be,
I'm going to in charge.
They like
that person.
You don't remember to be president.
Yeah.
I think and it's like,
look,
I don't really want to do this.
Yeah.
And I think the,
yeah,
that's different.
That's all hungry for the political life there,
there,
uh,
arrogant person that thinks that they should be in charge of it.
It's like now,
yeah,
I don't watch like on TV,
like,
so like me,
if,
uh,
if I watch,
um,
I dunno.
Like,
okay.
So,
well that's kind of a good example cause I'm interested in Hawaii,
so you know,
I'm going to like,
but like,
okay,
so on,
so I make videos,
right?
80 some,
some visual effects,
whatever.
There's a youtube channel called video copilot,
right?
So all of us,
it's mainly just tutorials on how to do stuff.
That's all it is really.
So when that,
like if a new video comes out of something,
man,
I'm all up in there,
all up in it,
but you don't care.
You're going to watch that thing and you're going to,
you're going to,
you're not even going to click on it.
Not even close.
No.
See what I'm saying?
Unless I was like,
hm,
I wonder if I'm going to take echoes job or yeah.
Or,
okay,
okay.
Case in point,
I'm not interested.
Right.
So I could barely even get through one of those videos.
I'd be like,
no,
I'm going to go over here and do burpees.
Yeah,
exactly.
So you're going to click on that video.
If I say,
Hey Jocko,
click on this video.
This will make,
you know,
you're broadening your horizon.
I Dunno,
whatever,
click on this video and just watch the whole thing.
Watch it five times.
Actually,
Bro,
when you're done watching it five times,
it's bad.
Everything went over your head.
Don't care.
You don't even care.
So advice from this book is put people that are interested in the job,
truly,
inherently interested in,
they're going to do a better work.
Even then maybe someone that's more talented than then they are
back to the book.
Other personal differences besides interests and likes and dislikes are
important,
especially for some military tasks.
One may feel,
one man may feel completely at ease in the transparent cage in which a
bombardier must sit while another ordinarily dextrous is so upset in the exposed
position that the pupils of his eyes dilate his fingers fumble and he cannot
manipulate the bom site properly.
So there you go.
You've got a guy that's probably a better,
maybe he has quicker reaction times,
but he's just scared to be inside the turret.
Two equally wise,
officers may not be equally good leaders.
One is at ease with his men,
talking with them freely,
getting their slant on matters of importance.
And giving his orders and directions readily.
The other,
although he wants his men to like him and respond alertly and willingly to him
as a leader,
cannot bring himself to feel free and confident with them and open up with them
in a way to gain their confidence and liking in turn.
The first is of course the better leader,
so then there you go.
That's like straight up,
hey,
this person,
if you're more comfortable talking to your troops,
they're going to sense that and you're going to be better than someone that's
comfortable talking to the troops.
Indeed,
leadership is the quality that the army most needs.
All advancement brings with it.
Responsibility and responsibility for the conduct of others requires leadership.
That's interesting because what's interesting about that is that is,
and it goes into this later on talking about the,
we probably won't cover it until the next podcast on this book,
but talking about the,
you know,
are leaders born or made and this is clearly leaning a little bit towards born
clearly,
which I agree with.
I think leaders are born and made.
Yeah,
it's both.
It feels like a lot of times when people use the expression are they born,
whether it be leaders,
whether it be whatever,
you know he's a natural whatever.
Um,
I get the expression and I understand and agree of course,
but technically like if you say if a leader is made or born,
born meaning like he wasn't trained at a very specific point to be a leader.
He brought to the training or to the position just a bunch of like talent or
whatever.
But he probably learned that through like his life,
what he was exposed to,
what he was,
you know.
But there are certain aptitudes that people have and those play an impact.
If you have somebody that's really articulate,
they're going to make a better writer than someone that's not her.
But even someone who's articulate,
they,
they learn that through sort of life.
There's no possibly,
but some of it maybe there's like a shorter tongue or something because it has
to be genetic is what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't know if there's an articulate gene.
There is an articulate gene for sure north on a gene.
It's your brain,
how much capacity do you have the process words quickly and assemble them
together into sentences and put them out to comprehendable statement?
How can you do that?
How well can you do that?
Yeah,
but you're not born knowing how to to I guess.
like a process and have the,
yeah.
You have what?
Yeah,
that's it.
What process or what size processors or do you have in your,
in your brain,
you've got the old four 86 was or do you got the new pentium,
whatever was probably like 10 years old.
Pentium,
you know,
it's like a I seven or eight nine.
I have no idea.
Anyway,
but no,
because there's articulate people who don't talk fast or don't.
Yeah.
That's able to assemble there.
Okay.
Here's another one,
and this ones,
and I've talked about these before,
but the ability to look at complex problems and simplify them.
Yeah,
sure.
Some of that is learned,
some people just are born with it.
Some people learn it in the streets.
Street.
Yeah.
I think my,
my,
I'm drawing back on my Bruce Saints background and I do think,
I believe I'm under,
I believe it's a belief that you get it from like,
like,
like your guarantee if you take someone that had a twin brother yeah.
And,
and you,
one of them would be more apt at some things than the other one.
There's gotta be some things that you are better at than your brother naturally
and some things that your brother is better at.
The new,
I don't know of any,
but the,
I mean,
put it this way,
all the differences that we have,
I feel like I can map it back to why because just being second born,
I was born in a little bit smaller to now look at me like a bigger,
I'm like,
I don't want to be here.
Especially people would compare to,
you know,
like growing up with a twin brother,
they always compare like all he's little bit tall.
Anyone yes.
Or whatever.
Oh yeah.
And the training that no more are there
anyway.
The point is,
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying you're,
I think you brew,
you're probably right,
of course,
but
I think it's mostly learned,
bro.
People have a certain genetic cognitive capacity without question.
Yeah.
That's not even debatable.
Yes,
I would not to be.
So what we're talking about is the ability to take that cognitive capacity and
steer it towards the articulation of language.
If you have more cognitive capacity,
you will be able to articulate language better.
And there's probably little modules inside the brain that are genetic that have
even more capacity for the grabbing and assembling of linguistic patterns
together where they flow off the tongue rapidly and sensibly.
And there's got to be part of your brain that's better at that just genetically.
Now,
of course,
if you spend a lot of time in that arena,
you will get better at it over time.
But there's gotta be some,
just like you have x amount of fast twitch muscle and Echo Charles,
like how hard did you work at your vertical jump?
Did you guys test that?
And Football?
Yes.
Okay.
What was the highest vertical jump you ever had?
39 and a half.
Okay.
That's pretty good.
Right?
Is there a war there,
people on your team that worked harder than you,
if not harder,
that never got to 39 and a half inches probably.
Yes.
Actually yes.
Affirmative cause I didn't really work exactly.
I knew this is a loaded question.
So yes sir.
So someone,
there was someone on your team that they,
they worked and they trained and they were doing jump squats and Bulgarian
lunges and split squats and they were just trying to get that vertical jump up.
They were wearing,
remember those shoes with the toes on them,
get the mops when to get them hops.
So this guy had all those things and you already got to 32 inches.
Right?
And he goes,
he was bummed.
But,
but that's what I'm saying.
He has a certain genetic capability.
There's physical capabilities that are genetic and there's some,
some mental capabilities that are genetic and both of them have a max capacity.
And that dude with the,
the toe shoes for vertical jump improvement at warm.
Awesome.
And there was a kid one time,
he lived across the street from me and he,
you know,
he's young.
He was,
this is when I was probably 25 hours in the day.
It was back in the day.
But this kid train all summer long with those shoes.
And he was,
he what he wanted to do is dunk a basketball and he did it.
He did it eventually,
but he worked hard.
There are some people that don't even have to work hard and they can dunk a
basketball.
They're just got it.
Yeah man.
My friend cake nuts who I mentioned Ken cake nuts.
Don't know who we're talking about.
Some,
some different attributes now.
Um,
he was like,
he always had like kind of like big,
it's called big muscle bellies,
like the party,
your muscle.
Anyway,
he had kind of big muscle genetic use,
a thinner guy,
but,
and he was always cut.
So even into adulthood he wouldn't have to watch his diet and you know,
meanwhile if it like a normal person,
if you watch your diet like a lot,
then you can get that cut.
You can get there all.
Yeah,
totally can.
But cake nuts.
He's just cruising,
just shred,
you know,
and then he like lifts a bunch of weights over the summer.
Who working on,
I gave him by the way and he listened,
but he comes back and he's just huge,
still got by the way.
So it's like Dang.
But you know,
he just has it like that.
There you go.
Genetic genetic differences and that's what they're talking about in this book.
And I think sometimes people's attitude nowadays,
it's like,
well,
you know,
you can do whatever you want.
Well took.
No,
actually you should find out what's good for you.
That's what you should look for me.
Yeah.
Like I was a radio man.
You know,
it's like a radio man.
Why?
Cause I was like smart,
but I was big enough to carry a radio.
Right?
If the small guys and a seal platoon,
they become the point man,
because you don't have to carry any extra weight.
Gentleman,
you're so right.
Like so.
Right.
And consider like major industries and we'll just say sports,
right?
Where it's like,
it's pretty clear when you win,
you win.
When you lose,
you lose sports,
right?
So get the established sports
with very,
very few exceptions is going to be the case.
You're going to get like,
okay,
football,
because there's a bunch of positions that do very different things.
The tight end,
he's going to be a certain bill.
Generally it's for sure the quarterback is going to be a certain build and
receiver.
Her,
me certain build the center and the line certain built like you grab a guy from
the line guard,
right?
One of the guys in the line,
you put him on defense as like a cornerback or something who needs literally
opposite after do that too.
It happened.
So no,
no,
no.
Just train them,
train on for 10 years,
no negative.
Probably make him better.
But you to make him successful.
Exactly.
Right.
So it's like,
it's such a clear example just because there's more on the line with that,
you know?
So if you're a youngster,
you should look at your attributes and see number one where your attributes fit
and then what your interests are.
Sometimes people get,
they're super interested and so they just try for it anyways,
you know?
And that's cool.
That's cool.
There's,
there's some people that we get really good at a sport but they're still not
good enough to go pro because they don't have the genetic
gifts that are needed.
And that's why it's so prevalent in such a like big deal when you do find that
like the super rare guy where it's like,
hey,
he's not really genetically gifted,
but he works so hard that he made it.
Absolutely.
That's like a guy in basketball who's like not tall,
not fast.
Yeah.
But he was pubes pretty fast though.
And he could jump or well,
but he's small.
You know,
it's interesting,
I was talking to Dallas,
who's the coach of the goals,
the San Diego goals hockey team.
But a few years ago,
not very long,
the hockey had become all these big giant guys,
you know,
six,
four,
five,
260 pounds.
He's big monster guys.
And that's where everyone had started going in that direction.
All the team,
there's getting bigger because you guys are massive and they can hate hard.
And then recently it started going back again to guys that were smaller and
quicker and could move faster.
So that's an interesting evolution,
but you can look at it,
you could have looked at it,
you know,
four years ago or whenever it was,
I don't really know.
But 10 years ago or whatever,
when you were five 11,
you're like,
Oh man,
I'm not big enough to play pro hockey.
But some kids were like,
you know what,
I'm five 11 and be fast.
Maybe faster than everyone.
Okay,
cool.
And he made it and now they're in the game.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
I'm not as familiar with like the necessities of being a good hockey player or
team as far as the physical attributes.
Um,
but like football,
I used that,
that example because the jobs of each position are so different.
I mean not each position,
but like the differences between,
you know,
like a quarterback wide receiver and then the difference between that and like
all line men.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So like basketball is different.
Even though they have different positions where everyone has to Sorta,
generally speaking,
of course there's exceptions,
but everyone's going to be tall.
No one's going to be like slow.
If you're like slow,
it's like that's a big kind of deal,
you know?
So everyone's a little bit more uniform.
Yeah.
Hockey scene or the same way.
More uniform.
Hockey's more uniform.
Seal platoon is not uniform because you've got a big 60 gunner gunner,
but,
but you know what?
Not all paid gunners are big.
Yeah.
Cause you can just be a tough 162 pound pig.
Just king.
Just kid grind it out.
Appointments usually a little bit smaller,
but that's,
but when you get to a seal
team,
guys look at you and you're like,
oh you're,
you're five,
seven year,
140 pounds.
You're going to be appointment.
That's the way it's going to work most of the time.
Sometimes you get them in a platoon and they're like,
we already got appointment.
Dude,
you're going to carry a pig here.
You go buck up and start doing some squats.
Moly.
All right.
Personality.
It takes more than brains to make a good soldier.
It takes guts,
it takes endurance,
it takes a willingness to do hard work.
It takes a,
a keen interest in doing the job well.
Psychologists wish they could give the army right now a method of measuring
these important pat personality assets tests that would be as accurate and
reliable as a test for measuring the ability to do arithmetic or aptitude for
learning radio code.
They can't,
some tests had been tried,
many have been found useless.
Few are promising.
You know what's interesting,
I just thought of this,
I went to communication school,
the,
the seal communication school and we had to learn Morse code and there was one,
I was probably 20 guys in my comms course and we all had to learn Morse code and
this was very clear that some people were better at it than others cause you had
to,
and we didn't have to send very fast,
we,
but we had to be able to receive like a certain amount of groups.
It's called the group.
It's five,
five letters in a group and they would just come back to d two d d d d d d d Dee
Dee.
And you had to be able to receive and write down what the letters were with no
mistakes.
But what's interesting is we all showed up.
No one knew any morse code when we showed up and there was a complete bell curve
when we got done,
you know,
some guys were really good at it naturally.
Some guys were horrible at it and it took every ounce of mental power for them
to figure out and get to be able to pass the test.
And I had a crazy guy that was teaching the comm school and someone would be
like,
hey,
um,
chief,
why do we have to learn,
you know,
Morris Code since no one uses it anymore.
He'd go and he'd say,
ah,
in the event of a nuclear holocaust,
Morse code,
ms,
the only thing that's going to be punching through the ionosphere,
and of course I was 18 years old and I was like,
oh dude,
that's right.
Right on.
I was,
my interest was piqued.
I was like,
Hey,
in event of a nuclear holocaust,
I'm going to be on the HF radio hammer and out Morris code to the troops.
Let them know what's up.
Well,
that makes sense.
How was stupid?
I was what we,
what it means to what you don't agree with that?
No,
dude,
if there's a nuclear holocaust,
I wouldn't be alive.
Well what if we would be dead?
But you,
you know what if you're like one of the only survivors or survivors like me,
but it's so man,
that's interesting that that where you'd have to,
I mean that small little thing that you just said where you have to,
it's less about putting it out.
It's more about receiving cause worst code.
You don't communicate necessarily pickers.
The reason I'm to,
here's the reasoning behind it.
If you want to send
Morse code,
you can send at whatever pace you want is the people are just going to sit there
and take the letters that your son did,
right?
They're not saying hurry up.
So you can send it whatever pace you want,
but receiving,
you gotta be ready and I forget what the minimum standard.
I think it,
well I want to say it was 20 groups of minute or something like that.
You want to pass?
You mean like not passing and I forget,
I forget,
but we weren't as good as like a regular navy guy who would just be,
I don't even know what,
but they way faster.
We were like knuckle draggers compared to them.
We had to learn every day and you had to do it every day and to test it out.
And some people test it out in a few weeks.
Some people didn't test out until the,
you know,
the last days sitting,
there's nuclear wars code gets,
do you,
you still know Morse code?
Not really.
What if he came in at like beep?
No,
I would need to brush up on it and brush up on it and which I need to do because
if there is a nuclear holocaust,
I want to be,
you know,
ready to get comms out,
HF coms and receive them.
Of course,
you know?
Yeah.
Check.
But it's such a clear example of,
and the guys,
it wasn't like on that bell curve of guys that were good and bad.
It wasn't like everyone that was a good seal was up at the top and the guys that
weren't good at Morse code were bad seals.
No,
it was like some of the guys were awesome guys and they sucked it Morse code and
some guys were marginal guys,
but they were great in Morse code.
And there is a perfect example,
like what do you do with that guy?
And we'll put them in to make them a radio man.
You know?
That's interesting that he,
I kicked nuts when he was going through,
I think it was bud.
No,
no,
no.
It was after buds.
He,
he kept saying like,
man,
actually my other friend Jeremy was telling me that,
oh yeah,
he's good at pretty much everything.
He's just really good at stuff except for picking locks.
It was like struggling with like bigger locks,
which is kind of a random thing to struggle with.
Picking locks is,
is a difficult thing and it's a,
it's more like playing a musical instrument that it is like doing a technical
skill where you do a,
B,
c and you get d no picking locks is like,
you're gonna to feel a little art man.
You got a feel for it.
And I've been with guys,
I was okay at picking locks.
The guy that I learned from was,
he could walk up and put the,
you know,
walk up to indoor Auburn stand,
not facing it and just stand there and just pick the lock open in seconds.
It's pretty incredible.
Kind of like on that,
that movie,
the Italian job you ever launched to that?
No,
he has a good one.
So this girl,
she was like the safe cracker,
like a den of thieves.
They're this group of the safe cracker.
Yes.
Her Dad was cracker.
It was like a genetic thing.
They're good,
you know.
So the dad passed it onto the,
you know,
it's like genetics.
Some people,
that's how you know.
Yeah.
Maybe the learned behavior as well as you know from the old men going on
back to the book.
One trouble is that a man's person.
Now this is important.
One trouble is that a man's personality changes in different situations.
For instance,
the man who is brave is a lion in the test room at a reception center.
May Not be so brave when he gets into combat.
The man who is able to make quick decisions wisely when things are quiet may go
to pieces when he is distracted by machine gun fire and do something that result
in his own death or the death of others and difficult situations that may the
reverse effects on some men.
Men who have never distinguished themselves in training camp may be come fired
with new spirit when going,
when the going gets tough,
astounding themselves and other men with what they can do an extreme emergency.
So that's obviously important too.
So even though you know someone,
you don't even know him,
you don't know what you're going to get.
You might have somebody that freaks out when things go sideways.
Next section.
Training makes the soldier.
When men entered the army,
they're told the importance in the fighting areas of taking cover from enemy
fire in slit trenches.
This point is emphasized in books,
lectures,
training,
films,
demonstrations and exhibits.
By the time the soldier reaches the battlezone,
he has learned that he should take cover in a slit trench whenever he stops.
That is one kind of learning.
In one way,
it is the most useful client with knowledge of how things should be done and why
they are important.
A soldiers equipped to act in new situations and there is nothing that produces
so many new situations as combat,
but this kind of learning unfortunately does not always result in action.
A soldier may know perfectly well that he should dig a trench.
You may have learned it from demonstrations exactly how to go digging it.
Yet when the enemy planes come overhead,
he may in his excitement,
forget that what he was learned in such emergencies,
he is more likely to act from habit.
Then from reasoning and sense,
habit formation is a further stage of learning.
It depends on practice,
experience and repetition.
No action ever becomes automatic by learning in words how to perform it,
but without actually practicing it.
But by repetition,
the operation of a machine or a rifle gets itself reduced to habit so that it
becomes almost entirely mechanical like walking.
You do not have to think about putting your left foot forward after planting
your right foot ahead.
That is because you have walked so much you could do,
you could not get that way merely from listening to lectures on how to walk.
If during maneuvers,
a soldier practices taking cover instantly whenever he sees or hears an air
attack warning or plane coming close,
he,
if he always throws himself flat when he first,
here's the sun whistle of a shell or the singing of bullets past his ears,
these actions soon becomes second nature to him.
That particular warning sights and sounds become fixed as signals for immediate
actions in real emergency.
The soldier does not have to stop and think about what he should do.
He just does it
straight forward.
That's why we roll in Jujitsu.
That's why egg need.
Look,
drilling is important.
I get it.
You got to learn the move,
but you got to roll.
Yeah.
Y a n one could argue that drilling it serves the same purpose.
Just in a more like specific kind of what you gotta do both.
Yeah.
Now that if you drill correctly,
but what you can't do is sit there and get shown to move.
Right,
right.
You got to do the move.
Yeah.
And I used to do that too and we'd have guys going through CQC training and a
lot of times,
you know,
instructor might want to hear himself talk a lot and explain things cause you
know,
it's a,
it's a pump to the ego.
When you get up there and you show people what was your,
how I did it,
did it look,
this is,
you know,
you get an instructor that wants to hear himself talk and meanwhile they sit
there and talk for 20 minutes.
Uh,
the seal platoon could have done three more runs through the kill house in 20
minutes.
So I'll tell you what,
say what you got to say,
say it quick and let the boys go pull that trigger.
Because that's how we get good by doing back to the book.
This sort of learning of minor importance in high school or college is basic in
the army.
That is wide drill is so important.
Why discipline is so essential in war games,
the soldier gets conditioned to all sights and sounds of battle.
In early training,
it may be possible to simulate realistically the noises of shells,
dive bombers and bursting bombs by recordings we produced by loudspeakers in
advanced training,
a soldier may be taught to lie flat on the ground,
while real bullets strike within a few feet,
close enough to cause San to fall on the back of his neck.
He knows he is safe as so long as he lies still,
but if you'd get up and run,
he will be killed.
That is good training for combat.
A real bullet forms,
much better habits than a lecture about a bullet,
such thoroughly drilled habits enabled the soldier to act when there is no time
for fought.
They ensure that he will act correctly in mechanically even when his mind is
confused and thinking is almost impossible
but knowledge of the science of warfare and practicing solving novel military
problems are important too because they enable the soldier to act wisely in the
thousands of unexpected emergencies that arise in battle.
Habit is safer than fought for standardized acts but it won't work for brand new
problems.
That is why we would train our guys in brand new problems all the time.
That way you get a protocol for how to,
how to handle brand new problems.
You start to understand what you're going to do.
Oh,
I don't know what's happening.
What do we do a step back.
I'm going to look around them and assess the situation.
I'm going to come up with some possible solutions.
I'm going to think about what the outcomes of those solutions are,
what the risks are and then it would make a decision we're going to move forward
in that direction cause like
confronting or dealing
with new problems or un charted situations or whatever.
The skill of dealing with that is like another skill in and of itself.
I think you're saying this like last start protocol and people were asking about
protocol protocol for handling new problems.
What do you do?
And eventually you get good at because of the slightly obvious first thing is
you do is you detach.
You have to take a step back.
You have to turn around and look around,
physically look around.
So detach,
look around,
make an assessment,
come up with possible solutions,
think about what the outcomes of those solutions might be and then pick the one
that has the best possible outcome.
Hmm.
Yeah.
And that's pretty different than like trained level 10 training.
Perfect.
Training on situation a,
And Q.
Because you merged,
you're going to get hit with Z.
Yeah.
When z hits,
it's like Dang can and then you've totally should.
I just got a message from a guy that was in,
uh,
police officers in a big firefight with some of his guys.
And he was literally said,
said,
I was like thinking to myself,
I'll get covered.
Move.
Here's what we're going to do.
Prioritize and execute.
He's going through.
He's like,
there was pretty awesome,
pretty awesome to hear that.
To hear a guy say,
Yep,
I can hear your voice saying,
cover,
move,
put down color of fire right now,
they were not 21 minute firefight,
which is a long day long.
That's a long firefight for,
especially for police officers.
Back to the book,
drill for combat changes.
The recruit squad into an efficient fighting machine training can convert an
unorganized civilian group into an organized unit with deadly power,
military confident competence.
Moreover,
strips war of its most repulsive and paralyzing horrors
and knowledge takes from the enemy,
his most potent,
potent,
and effective.
What?
Weapon?
Surprise,
drill.
Combat Training,
practice and discipline combined with the experience in war are things that make
America's combat troops into seasoned troops.
So even taking away the ability for the enemy to surprise you.
It's like we talked about before.
If if you try and move on me in Jujitsu and,
and I've never seen it before,
there's a chance it's going to work.
There's the best possible chance go to work and as soon as I know what that move
is,
I mean it then it's the chances of it working are a lot less,
a lot less.
Significantly less.
Yeah.
That's why role playing is so important.
Well,
in the business world is very important because we can come at you with
different things that a subordinate,
it's going to save you or even up the chain of command.
If I had to go brief my boss on something that we were pretty sure he didn't
like and I was like,
okay,
I go,
you be the boss,
you come at me with all the negatives about the plan I've come up with and then
we do that.
So then when I go in,
I've already seen these even one time.
Like I said,
one one time makes an incredible difference.
Okay.
Back to the book and we need speed.
Democracy's always have to hurry up at the last minute.
The enemy is always facing us,
ready,
trained,
and there isn't much time.
We must take advantage of every possible shortcut toward the goal of creating
season troops,
troops armed with adequate,
adequate training.
The first shortcut is an understanding of the few facts about how learning takes
place.
The most important requirement of learning is incentive.
Men Marching to drill reluctantly can no more be taught swiftly and efficiently
than a jeep can be taught to run on an empty tank.
People need incentive,
but fortunately for the army's instructors,
there is a power.
There is a powerful motive are furnished by the situation itself.
No false incentives need be thought up and provided.
The enemy has attacked us.
We're at war and no man wants to go out and face the that enemy unprepared.
No American wants to see American soldiers killed needlessly in unmatched
battle.
No one wants to see our armies defeated and the Gestapo policing New York City
success itself is reward to soldier.
It makes him proud.
This is when they start,
I forgot to say that I'm skipping chunks of this book,
but this is where he's talking about how the incentives that that uh,
that a soldier could have.
His commander may commend him,
but it's usually enough if he sees that as CEO has noticed that he has done a
good job.
Good morale depends on such rewards.
Such awards by his officers and approval from his own comrades in general.
Reward is much more effective for learning then is punishment.
Yeah.
This is good.
Punishment excites resentment and tends to make the soldier anxious not to
comply.
If he can get away with carelessness or disobedience,
that's if you could remember that right there,
this podcast is worthwhile.
If you remember the fact that as a leader,
if you're,
if you're constantly punishing people,
what you're doing is making them resentful and encouraging them to not comply
and rebel against you and try and get away with carelessness and disobedience.
Think about your kids do right.
Cause we do that with the kids better to what I told you.
And then when they try,
they're trying to skate around you.
Yeah.
Reward.
Keeps his attention on the business in hand.
Punishment tends to shift his attention from the task to his own troubles.
The best kind of reward because it is most effective in learning is the glow of
satisfaction that a man has when he knows he has done something correctly and
well it has clicked.
The most effective punishment is the surge of disgust that comes when he knows
he's missed the target.
That's all I've all known is always good
to have a reminder because it's natural to like,
I mean with your kids or whatever the,
when they do something wrong it's because that'll stick out more in your mind,
you know,
if they do something right,
especially if it's not for the first time,
it's like,
oh yeah,
that's how you're supposed to do it.
Right.
Kind of thing.
So it doesn't stick out in your mind to commend them.
Yeah,
like encouragement,
reward kind of thing.
Like it's,
you know,
it's more powerful.
But then in your mind as kind of the teacher or whatever the,
when they fail to miss the mark,
you know,
especially if they do it.
Like if they're having a hard time with something,
you know,
like to learn stuff,
you got to do it over and then they're having a hard time,
I don't know,
swimming,
potty,
train on an or whatever when they don't miss the mark yet.
So you,
it comes with the frustration sometimes can't do that,
can't show that kind of thing.
But even though it's like the most readily available,
like reaction,
you know the,
when they fail so you get so yeah,
to be reminded of it helps I think.
Yeah,
it's an important point.
Next,
this is why the army has to,
has been right to reduce greatly the emphasis on close order drill in recent
years in the light of modern knowledge and in the view of modern conditions of
warfare.
This drill conflicts of the methods which must be used in battle.
So closing Bridgette drill is our close order drill is when,
you know,
you'd see Marines,
army,
they're like a handy the rifle back road forest and everything's all,
it's like parade type stuff.
Yeah.
That's a close order drill is.
And they used to do more of it and now he's saying that they do less.
Back to the book.
In the drill of the early basic training,
the whole emphasis on teaching is on teaching the soldier to respond to spoken
commands when he,
yeah,
when he goes into combat,
smoking spoken commands become impossible.
The human voice is silent in the din of battle.
If commands are given it all,
they must be given in the form of a nudge,
a kick or an arm and hand signal and in drill,
the soldier also forms the habit of acting shoulder to shoulder with other men.
He comes to rely on being in a group on doing what the other men do when they do
it.
Getting combat such close order work would be suicidal.
Men are on their own.
Men are then on their own or in twos or threes.
They must keep at a distance from each other,
both to do much of their fighting skillfully and to avoid making crowded targets
for the enemies,
bombs,
shells or bullets.
This means that an advanced trading men must learn new habits which conflict
some respects of the old.
That's not good.
The basic rule of learning is this.
Do it right from the beginning because if you form wrong habits,
you must unlearn them before you can learn what is right.
The rule to follow is never prepare for combat by learning to act on a signal
that cannot be given after combat has started
and then it talks about how to increase the speed of training.
Here's some things to do to increase the speed of training.
Number one,
do things right the first time.
Number two,
keep constant checks that you know immediately whether you are doing right or
making a mistake.
That's a good one.
That's why I like shooting steel so much.
We were shot steel before.
No,
as soon as you,
as soon as you pull the trigger and the shot goes,
do you know if he hit it or not?
And so it's completely gratifying.
Make no unnecessary motions.
If you flourish your hands or putter around with your tools like it or not,
these profitless motions will become habit to it's want to do everything as
clean as you can,
do things in the same order and in the same way,
stick to this rule as far as possible.
Avoid unnecessary lead links in the chains of your learning.
This was interesting at,
well I'm not going to read it cause it went on about learning Morris Code in
how,
how you can put these multiple different steps in to learn it when in fact you
could just say that noise means this letter.
You don't have to translate it to the little things in your mind or the sounds
in your mind.
The dit,
dit dosh.the.dot Dash Dash,
dash or when you don't need to translate that in your mind.
That sound means this letter and you can get there quickly like a lake.
Lloyd is language.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like when you're fluent in a language you don't think in English anymore.
I don't.
I've rarely got maybe got into that a little with a few parts of Espaniol when I
was in college,
but I never carried on a conversation without translating what I was hearing,
which is completely lame.
The clunky for sure.
That's part of the process,
I would think.
Yeah.
Number six,
aim at first for smoothness of performance rather than speed.
Number seven,
be sure to understand what you are trying to do,
what final objective your aiming aiming at.
That's important.
People should really,
you whoever your training needs to understand what they're trying to do.
I've found this an early Jujitsu.
There was a lot of lacking in this where you didn't understand that getting the
underhooks was a thing they just understood like for this particular move,
you put your arm here.
I didn't understand it was a whole thing would have been better to be like,
hey,
you're always looking for the underdogs.
Make sense?
That's actually what Dean taught me.
Tony.
He is the one that taught me that too,
and this is when he was a blue belt.
Number eight,
learn series of actions rather than single moves.
That's good for Jujitsu as well.
You don't just want to learn the one.
You want to learn how all those three,
four,
five moves tied together and how you set up the counters and how the counter
leads to another trap.
Nine keep on practicing.
10 overlearn.
Number 11 relax.
Interestingly enough,
until people to relax and larks hoarder
back to the book ways have been worked out to help cut down the time required to
master a subject to read and understand a book or assignment to solve a problem
or to memorize a rule or formula.
The man in the army,
this is,
this is about studying and I was like,
yeah,
I don't know if I'm going to put this in there,
but then all you know,
people,
our students,
we will add a new job.
They got to learn something and this is the most cold blooded way to talk about
learning.
The man in the army should not allow noise or other distractions or
interruptions to put them off his work.
Working under such difficult circumstances is direct training for actual
fighting conditions.
Oh,
so there's some annoying things going on when you're trying to,
you know,
read a book.
Cool.
Learn to ignore them
in the field.
The most in the field,
the most vital and difficult decisions must be made in the midst of the most
violent distractions and under all sorts of physical and mental strains.
The officer had to wait until he could be free of noise or disturbance before he
could work out a problem or make a decision would be useless in the army if he's
used to it,
a certain amount of noise and confusion may actually stimulate the army man to
do better thinking if it's convenient,
a definite time of the day should be assigned for studying.
The mind can be trained to be ready for work in a certain hour,
so this happens as much the same way as you begin without.
It'd be and thinking about food or some other set time for the same reason,
it might be desirable to have a certain place set aside for study,
even if it is just your bunk in a noisy barracks or tent than the act of sitting
down in that place.
Will immediately form habit put you in the proper frame of mind for mental work.
If you are lucky enough to have a desk or a corner for your study,
don't spoil its value by using it for relaxation or nothing,
but even if they are insistently disturbing,
it's insistently disturbing is nearly always possible to ignore distractions and
get down to the business at hand.
The mind is an excellent seed net.
You can read the newspapers and never see the advertisements.
You would hear a strange footsteps across the room yet never noticed the loud
ticking of a clock on your own table,
the telegraph,
or can sleep through the long continuous sounding of his instrument yet wake at
once his own call when his own call comes in with the right dots and dashes and
the same way it is possible to make yourself deaf and blind to all sorts of
sights and sounds except those directly concerned with the problem being
studied.
Do you get annoyed when there's,
when you're trying to do what?
Do you listen to?
Music when you're doing work?
Depends on the work,
but yes.
Interesting.
At first it is fatiguing to shut out distractions.
You know what I'm like,
I was just,
as I was asking her quad,
this is what I'm like,
if I let something started to bother me,
then it just bothers me a tub and,
and for some reason,
if I just don't let it bother me that it's fine.
Like if my,
my wife's in the other room with,
you know,
my youngest daughter and they're playing a game and they're making noise and
having conversations about it and whatever.
If I'm,
if I'm in the wrong mindset,
if I don't do what this book is telling me to do,
which is just,
you just shut it out.
Like I'm like a,
like a legit do disposed to do.
Oh,
there's some noise over there,
whatever.
Just lock it up.
Otherwise it's what weakness.
Otherwise it's major weakness.
What about like snoring?
Um,
like you know,
your year like a roommate or what?
But you know,
you know,
I have a,
we have a mutual friend that when we used to go to fights,
we would stay in one room and the story would be pretty crazy.
But I would normally sleep right through it.
Yeah.
If I know what's happening.
It's weird.
Like my,
my crying kids when they were babies,
they would make a wake up,
my wife and my wife and I went to sleep right through it.
But if there's a noise outside the house or whatever,
I'm awake.
And she,
since her throat,
it's like the perfect combination.
The girl,
the mother and the crying child.
I think that's a genetic thing.
I think we're like a crying baby.
It's like,
well you know,
did you get a genetic thing?
Did you learn that in Brookside?
The halls of Bro Science.
Does that make sense?
Yes it does.
And is there a part of me,
cause you know when,
when we had small children,
my wife didn't work.
I did.
So
that was her roles and respond my roles and responsibility where go to the,
you know,
do my job during the day.
And whenever I was in the navy,
her roles and responsibilities were take care of those kids.
So she,
there's probably a huge part of that where I'm maybe in the beginning when the
first baby was crying and I was like,
oh,
what's that?
And then eventually I just said,
oh,
she's got it.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Got It handled.
Yeah.
Uh,
going back to the book,
at first it is fatiguing to shut out distractions.
You actually make your muscles tense in your effort to attend a business later
you get,
so that things that distract you,
no longer worry.
You know,
it's,
when I'm on an airplane,
you're wrapped a screaming baby on an airplane and no factor to me,
it's like no factor whatsoever.
What about whatever we talked about while we were on there?
Oh,
okay.
You brought it up too.
I was like,
oh hey that scream you.
Is that,
is that bothering you?
This doesn't bother me at all.
Still later they help and find that you miss them if they disappear like the man
who is startled when his clock stops ticking or the radio.
At first it prevents you from studying,
but if you keep it on continuously you may get so you cannot study without it.
Okay.
Having set the stage as well as possible for most effective study.
The next important preparation is develop absorbing
interest in the material to be mastered.
It is not necessary to resort to self delivered mental pep talks.
Enthusiasm grows naturally out of the realization that a study is important in
reaching the desirable goal that it will satisfy your curiosity and we'll give
you a chance to exercise some special talent.
Isn't that funny how that could very well be a self pep talk that those words
are a true
true.
The chief aide to learning however is understanding when something makes sense,
when it all fits in with what you already know,
that it is easily filed away in the ready reference system of your memory where
it can be recalled later at need.
Learning without understanding is hard.
You probably learned the multiplication tables that way.
Learning with understanding may require no effort at all,
so try to understand,
see relationships.
If chapter eight depends on chapter two then you are uncertain about chapter
two,
turn back,
see the dependence,
work it out for yourself rather than read it again.
If you learn a new scientific fact,
see whether you can find instances of it in your own experience and then when
you think you know it,
when you think you know what you have studied,
say it all over to yourself in your own words that tests understanding.
Sometimes it gets clear for the first time as you explain it to yourself and if
you can't get it said to your own satisfaction,
then chances are you really do not understand it and what you don't understand,
you won't remember.
That's good information right there for the students of the world which everyone
should be.
This is other good information solving problems.
The method of bird's eye view first applies to rapid problems solving as well.
Haste to often temps people to plunge into working out the first part of a
problem where the easy parts before the entire problem is clearly in mind.
This may result in a false start in needless work.
Read the whole problem through first use Karen,
setting the problem down.
If you are new at this particular sort of problem,
don't try to take shortcuts in this.
A little extra time used on formulating the problem in your mind or on paper can
save a great deal of time in finding the solution.
The next step is to rapidly review all possible methods of solving the problem
until you find the the one that seems right.
Then try that.
If that file fails to work,
try another.
That's the way you work with a mechanical puzzle.
You should use the same method on a technical problem.
And this is the same exact thing that I was saying about how to solve like a
complex tactical scenario.
You'd take a step back.
You look at what the promise,
you make sure you understand the whole problem.
You just don't say,
oh we're getting shot out from over there.
We're gonna change everything and focusing on now cause you're getting flanked
or you're getting,
you're getting some by fire over there.
So you take a step back,
you analyze the situation,
you make sure you understand it to the best of your possible ability,
and then you start saying,
okay,
what are my options?
Once you figured out what your options are,
you quickly assess what would the results of those options be?
What's the upside,
what's the downside?
And then you pick one of them.
You go,
that's so funny.
That exact thing.
Not as complex,
but that exact thing played itself out in my life here recently.
So we've got a trampoline,
right?
You don't want those big ones for your kids and you've got to put it together.
It didn't look at the whole instructions.
Well,
I do this thing where it was that that they said,
I forget how they call it,
said the words that they use in the book right there that you just said,
but basically I looked at it.
I didn't understand the whole thing.
I didn't read the whole answer.
I don't know.
I looked at it,
I was like,
all right,
I understand.
I see.
I see the problem I'm dealing with here.
So I did it.
And how'd that work out for it,
Bro?
Three separate times I went,
you know how like at a certain point you got to make sure you've got to do
something.
It's like that kind of,
so I had to make sure that the springs were aligned in a certain way for a
reason that's going to come up later that she didn't know.
So I'm like,
sure,
I get it.
I'm smart.
I've put on all this through the whole thing.
Everything took like an hour,
just over an hour to do it.
So I keep going and keep going.
Keep going.
Now it's time to put up like the,
uh,
the,
you know,
the little barriers that your kids don't fly off their trampoline,
but the springs,
the springs are not aligned with the hooks there,
so I can't put up the barriers.
Yeah,
it's a bummer,
isn't it?
It's a freaking bummer.
Yeah.
And it happened again with another thing later.
Actually it happened four times,
but the fourth thing was just the little basketball hoop and I was like,
it's not worth it.
I never put it on the basketball hoop but haven't,
hey,
a fire were to under it to read the whole thing,
read the whole Dang thing and I wouldn't have written,
it would've saved me like three hours
back to the book when you're stumped and maybe because you have taken the wrong
approach to the promise,
easy to get into a Rut in thinking it is hard to shake yourself loose from one
point of view and see a completely new it.
This stuff is so simply stated that it's a,
you underestimate the power of what's being said right here.
Yeah.
This stuff is lifesavers.
You tend to keep going back and repeating this same old kind of attack that is
always it failed.
It's like feeling in the same,
it's like it's like feeling in the same pocket six times,
six times when you've lost your cigarettes and cannot find them.
Especially.
Is it hard to try new methods when you are tired or nervous over your failure to
get the right answer?
At such times it is best to close your book and work on something else or to do
something outdoors with fresh air or even if you can afford the time,
take a nap when you come back to your problem and the,
the new approach may come to you in a flash and from then on,
the work may go quickly and smoothly.
Yeah,
I,
I have to actually,
that's one of those things I'm pretty instinctive on a lot things that I do in
terms of things that I talk about in the way I actually apply them in my life,
I'm pretty good at most of them.
Most of them a hug.
I'm not even,
I don't have to consciously,
I can kind of look back and go,
oh,
he asked me what I did and I'm pretty stoked on it.
I can do that,
especially in Jujitsu.
I can get in a Rut
and be like,
oh,
I'm just going to do this right here and it should work because I've done it
before and it's going to work this time and I'll have to constantly be like,
oh you,
you're,
you're beating your head against the wall.
You don't do it anymore.
And I'll have to do a different approach.
But I mean it's kind of demonstrates your humility because you've always like
every time we roll in and actually when I see you rolling with other like really
good guys,
it seems like you adapt and make little changes way quicker than most people in
for Dang.
Sure.
Way quicker than me.
I feel like I'm all that,
like what you just said,
I feel like that's just a hundred percent know what I'm saying.
But I'm sure I'm okay at it.
I mean,
I know I'm okay at it,
but even me at this point I'll be like,
oh,
he's not going to put his arm there.
You've tried it three times in a row working.
You need to do something else.
Yeah.
You can like recognize,
I recognize when I'm beating my head up against the wall and that's not a good
feeling
and it's both.
The great feeling is as soon as you do something different,
generally you,
you may not get total success but you won't get the same outcome because the
outcome was failing,
which we don't like know
how to make learning stick.
The two basic principles of learning anything,
our interest and participation,
it is not true.
That repetition alone is the basis of learning something.
Well,
a man who repeats an act again and again with his mind only half of what he is
due.
It was mind only half on what he's doing.
May indeed learn it,
but he will learn it neither quickly nor well.
Fortunately doing a thing and practicing it usually reinforce a man's interest
so that there is really only one important principle interest at the bottom of
learning.
Active participation is secured by practice.
Lectures are used only when preliminary explanation at some length is needed or
when men cannot be put through the work itself.
You're not only told how to fire a rifle,
you or helped actually to do the firing and you work out of doors in the way
that you will later work in combat.
You do under instruction what later on you are going to have to do in combat
yourself.
So you've got to do these things.
Interest is secured in a variety of way,
number of a variety of ways.
Number one,
the personality of the instructor is important.
It should be dynamic and fort.
It should be a dynamic enforceful person who appreciates the fact that learning
takes time and that some men are slower than others.
He must stimulate his men to want to learn to instruction must finally become
individual.
There must be close contact between some instructor in every soldier.
Three,
the relation of the learning to the problems of combat must always be stressed
for,
although nonessentials are an omitted in army teaching,
it is important that the soldier should understand the basic principles of what
he is doing.
If he is learning how to use a machine that he should know how the machine
works.
Okay,
critical.
And number five,
the soldier must also have full knowledge of the purpose of what he learns of
why he needs to know it.
Only with such knowledge can his interest be at the highest and only with such
knowledge is he able to adapt what he has learned to different circumstances
that arise in combat.
So we've got to know why.
It also says here that all army commanders are leaders and teachers.
So if you're a leader,
you are a teacher.
Talking a little bit here about efficiency and trading,
the simplest kind of learning is to learn by trial and error.
But this isn't the best,
the most efficient way.
It wastes too much time.
And so the army never uses it except in solving original problems where one
method after another may be tried or at least imagined.
So trial and error is never the best.
Here's a good one.
In battle,
a leader can give orders,
but only brief ones.
Sometimes by signal.
The soldier receiving such an order must also,
yeah,
see the battle situation right around him in deciding how to best carry out that
order.
Next,
how to speed up training.
Okay,
we'll to learn.
Okay.
Uh,
soldiers.
Common Sense tells him that he must learn how to fight before he meets the
enemy.
Number two,
interest.
Yeah.
Number three,
disciplined.
Yeah.
Soldiers are trained to realize the serious importance of the things they are
taught.
How much these things we'll meet in combat later on.
Number four,
individual instruction.
Number five,
experience of success.
Army instructors try their best to see that each man does a thing right the
first time even by holding his hand and putting it through the correct movements
if necessary.
Number six,
elimination of nonessentials.
You only supposed to be learning things that you actually need to know.
Number seven,
all around attack every possible way of reaching the soldiers.
Student mind is utilized.
Yeah.
And then this instruction is immediately put to use in action on the drop.
Soldiers learn by doing so as far as possible.
Instruction is capped.
Practical and concrete.
If it instructor puts too much emphasis on training men in the particular
details of doing a job,
the soldier fails to get a clear understanding of the result aimed at it.
Although men and training,
although in training men in many different army jobs,
adequate attention must be paid to the detailed steps to be taken to reach the
final objective.
The aim itself must also be made entirely clear to the soldier.
This is cool.
And I trained a little kids in Jujitsu and be like,
you just got to get around their legs.
Yeah.
Did you tell them that?
And they'll figure it out,
how to do it and then when they get stumped,
you teach them some actual technique.
Otherwise he's apt to become confused in battle if the situation changes and he
cannot follow the steps in exactly the way he was taught in training
efficiency in the army,
every ounce of the soldiers energy should be concentrated on the defeat of the
enemy whenever he wastes his strength on any sort of activity that does not
contribute to that one,
and it is an effect.
A casualty.
No.
Where is efficiency more important than in combat there?
Every man must work at the very peak of his powers.
His eyes must see better than the enemy's eyes.
His ears must hear better.
He must think better on this victory.
Depends.
We re weariness tired hands or eyes or nervous system.
Anything that reduces the soldiers efficiency at a critical moment in combat may
cost him his life.
It may cost the army apposition and advance a battle.
Okay.
The enemy usually refuses to recognize the end of a work day.
Nature often provides the only lighting bomb holes.
Ensure ventilation.
When a soldier gets an actual combat,
what he is called upon to do seems to have no similarity at all to anything he
had ever done in a civilian job.
There is no routine in battle,
no standardization,
no monotonous repetition.
Each moment is a challenging new experience calling for new decisions and fresh
insight.
It is hard to see where the combat soldier can get any help at all from what
he's learned about efficiency in a factory far from the battlezone.
That is why a soldier in training must learn from the start to cut out useless
and roundabout movements that take needless time,
seconds count
and a soldier's energy counts too.
He can't afford to get worn down before his job is done.
He must keep his speed and accuracy up to top notch performance and he
blundering combat may be fatal there.
He may not be able to miss an AME again.
He may never have another chance.
No,
we get into this last little section that we're going to cover today.
It's about fatigue,
sleep,
that other enemy
fatigue is a fifth column enemy that is always ready to infiltrate and attack.
No Man can stick at a job for long periods through the day and night and
continue at top notch performance,
especially if his job involves using a great deal of strength,
keeping alert and making accurate split second decisions.
So you're allegedly need rest.
I posted the other day,
sleep is the enemy and people get,
so it's a song by Danko Jones and it's a great song.
Sure.
But,
and you know,
I kind of do feel that way,
you know,
cause it's pretty easy just to fold to sleep and you could spend all day in bed.
I know you don't see it that way,
but I kind of knew.
But sleep is the enemy.
Dislike food is the enemy.
Yeah.
Abusing.
It
could point just how long men can work and continue to do their best.
Depends upon a great many different things.
It depends first upon the man.
It depends also on the type of work.
It depends upon the conditions of the work upon the food,
eating upon rest obtained during the job upon worry and excitement and finally
upon the necessity for action,
a man can run fast and long if death or the devil is behind him,
he can fight hard for unbelievable lengths of time if there can be no retreat or
a victory is in sight.
Most hazardous is the fatigue which comes from spurts of extreme effort,
the greatest of which a man is capable.
Such supreme effort seldom if ever occurs in any job on the home front.
It does occur in sport.
It does occur in battle spurred by the necessity necessity to extraordinary
violence.
A man may actually put out so much effort that he burns up his body fuel at a
rate eight times more than the normal rate.
I have no idea where they got these numbers eight times more.
That's a pretty accurate,
this,
he cannot keep up more than a few minutes at a time.
Otherwise the sugar in his blood will fail.
We'll fall to a critically low level.
His heart will fail,
is collapse or even death will follow.
What do you think bro?
Science right there.
Well,
I mean then you make a good point where you,
where he got these,
I dunno where he got those numbers from.
People get Rhabdo yes.
And,
and,
but you get rhabdo you don't like fail on the moment.
Your heart doesn't fail.
Yeah.
Well the first thing I thought of is like in Jujitsu or MMA where you get to
like be adrenaline dump,
right?
Because your,
your soul like,
I mean it's through Adrenalin button.
Like it's these external circumstances.
It's like you're on the stage,
you know,
usually it's an inner competition.
It's not necessarily training.
So you're on the stage,
so it's when it's do or die,
do or die.
It's not,
but that's what you guys are.
Yes.
But,
so I was just thinking like if this is true,
like when a guy gets gassed in the UFC and he just can't go on.
But then what if somebody came in there with a machete and was like,
run a hack you to pieces.
What do you think the guy would do?
He'd run.
Yeah,
but that's like another level of stress that's do or die do or die out there on
the UFC or whatever.
And that's not accurate.
It's very inaccurate.
But as an example,
it feels like that's,
you know,
like they're still,
but they're using like probably eight times the energy,
you know,
cause there's so pumped up because of their onstage and stuff,
the nerves and all that stuff.
So it's like that,
you know,
it's another weird one when someone gases or whatever and then they ended up
winning and then they get that other surge [inaudible] a couple of 10 seconds
ago.
Why don't you put that effort out Bro.
Yeah.
So that,
that proves,
I wrote about this in the field manual.
Like,
sometimes you gotta use emotion and sometimes you've got to use logic because
someone's going to let that emotion come out yet.
So,
but all that,
the thing is like,
that does sound funny and look funny.
If a guy likes seems to be sort of gas and then write the literally the second
he wins,
he's,
he's running with his hand in there when you know,
but all that is,
that's not like a,
um,
like a maybe a slacker Thurston,
nothing like that.
That's like just the stress.
And winning is like,
I don't know if I'd call it a stress,
but I guess this is what I heard.
This is bro Science,
I heard this from people,
I need this in any official thing,
but you get like this boost of like hormones,
like testosterone and all these crazy hormones when you win a fight.
So it's maybe to that.
So it's like,
man,
it's not like it's controllable.
You'd have to actually be,
be confronted with a stimulus of winning for that tree to get that boost.
You know,
just like you're confronted with a stimulus of the crowd to get that overdrive
scenario where using eight times the energy
back to the book yet such fatigue,
fatigue does not always make you inefficient if you have strong enough need or
desire for action.
I like that right there.
Yeah.
That's that machete scenario that you just introduced.
Sometimes I wonder if I'm like perpetually in a state of like war.
I wonder that my brain too,
because sometimes I can't
sleep at all.
I believe that.
Yeah.
And I,
because I want to get up.
I'm not like that all the time.
I mean I do.
There's,
there's definitely days where I sleep really soundly.
Yeah.
But a lot of times it's like,
no,
it's not happening cause I got stuff I got to do word what a war over here on my
end over here,
I understand.
Yes.
Mental work and emotional strain or also fatiguing,
but the man who gets tired from mental work where the strain of responsibility
and worry has additional problem.
He may not consume the sugar in his blood as does the man engaged in a violent
physical worker.
Combat his blood,
therefore gets out of balance as bro Science coming covenants and the rest of
sleep may not readily restored.
It's actually weird because it's both sides,
but it makes sense.
Yeah.
I guess all bro Science kind of makes sense.
That's why it's Bro Science,
right?
It is good for the man who's been under this sort of strain to get some sort of
physical exercise.
A swift game of tennis,
a long walk or a turn at shopping would.
A second effect of fatigue is the tired feeling.
I think that's funny.
This is nature's natural protection against over fatigue.
When a man feels tired,
it becomes increasingly difficult for him to go on with his job.
He is more and more eager for rest and sleep.
Less and less able to spur himself on to go another mile.
The best antidote for this feeling of tiredness is high morale and the example
of other men.
It is the man working alone who has the hardest job in combating his own desire
to lie down and sleep,
but the most important effect of fatigue is the effect it has on work.
When a man is tired,
he doesn't,
he cannot do his very best.
The amount of work he is able to do falls off and the quality of his work
suffers too.
He does not see it as well,
does not hear as well,
nor is he so alert.
His movements may become clumsy and bungling in loss of loss and efficiency.
Strange as it may seem,
is not always related to feelings of fatigue.
A man may feel very tired when he has not been working particularly hard,
but is merely board or untrusted an interested in his work or when the
ventilation is so bad that he gets dopey.
This is important.
I think on the other hand,
a man really close to exhaustion may be so excited by his work that he's unable
to rest and does not feel tired at all.
Oh yeah,
so consider this and probably think about testimony for some reason.
Yeah,
it is.
That's what I think.
And consider this like in Jujitsu,
right?
Or like right now,
if I were to talk enough smack to you right now,
like no matter how you feel,
you can be tired,
you can be a one hour sleep,
you can be doing all this stuff like before and whenever you can be terrified
talking enough smack and I challenge you to roll outside.
You'll probably do it there.
There's no problem it's on.
But if I say okay,
after this go like run on a treadmill,
it's easier.
It's easier output
anyway.
Debatably easier to run on a treadmill.
But man,
you ever ran a day?
You used,
have you ever run on Treadmill,
treadmill?
Probably 10 times in my whole life.
And you know,
I used to get into the trip moan,
but man,
if when you,
when that boredom hits you probably you're like,
I can't run one more step on this damn thing.
Even though I could easily go train right now with like a bunch of good guys,
you know?
So it's like,
it's that exact thing when you get bored.
Like just the littlest bit of fatigue is going to jam you up big time,
but even if you're really fatigued and you're doing something fun,
you'll go,
oh yeah for sure.
That's why Jujitsu such good exercise cause it's fun.
So true men differ considerably in the rate at which they get tired on the same
job.
They differ even more in their rates of recovery after work is over.
There is almost no general rule as to what will happen except that recovery is
very rapid at first and slows down as the rest of the state is approached.
In fact means however,
that a lot of good can be got out of short rest and that many short rests are
better than one long one.
That makes sense to me.
Taking a little power nap,
students learn best if they did not do all learning at once.
Do not try and cram up before examinations,
but study a little and then quit for a while for a day or two.
In industry efficiency is highest when rest pauses are ranged at frequent
intervals.
I agree with that.
Although some I just power through stuff
so it does not pay to overwork workers or soldiers.
Some fatigue is on avoidable and much fatigue must be undergone in the process
of toughening a soldier,
but chronic fatigue is not to be found along the shortest road to victory.
So don't get tired.
Now it gets real specific on sleep.
You can stay up all night and keep awake.
And this,
I was surprised how accurate this reflects me.
Hmm.
I think you'll find it accurate as well.
You can stay up all night and keep awake.
Provided you are active,
provided you keep using some muscles,
at least the speaking muscles.
You can march all night,
play poker all night,
fight all night and talk all night.
You will likely,
you will be likely to get terribly sleepy somewhere between zero 300 and zero
600 unless you were doing something exciting or intensely interesting.
But you can get through that,
provided your active.
So like this would happen a lot.
You got on a patrol and you patrol all night to get to a position and then it's
now three o'clock in the morning and that's when you get tired.
Four o'clock in the morning you haven't gone to at and that's when you get
tired.
Then this happens,
um,
of do actually continue on.
That does not mean however,
that you can read study all night using few muscles other than those of your
eyes.
If you have to study all night,
you may need to read out loud or stand up to read
by the time.
Cause basically,
and that's totally true,
right?
If you have work to do and you're up working,
it's fine.
But if you,
if you going to read this book in the next 10 hours and you're falling asleep,
and that's one of the reasons why if you like,
let's say of a normal schedule job,
like a nine to five and then you want to work out or good Jujitsu or something
after work,
don't go home because when you go home to shut down on the couch for a second or
even if you just like,
you know,
just talk to your wife or whatever,
it's like
rather than going straight to the gym and you're,
you're,
that might be the best advice you've ever given.
Seriously.
Like if you want to train,
don't go home,
go to the gym.
That's very good advice.
Then it goes on in.
It says by breakfast time you'll be getting less sleepy.
This is totally true.
If you stay up and then once the sun coming up,
you can get through the next day pretty well.
You may feel tired,
especially you've been awake march every especially you've been marching or
walking to keep awake.
You won't feel fresh.
You'll feel uncomfortable,
but other people will not notice anything wrong with you unless you sit down to
relax with nothing important or interesting to do,
then very likely you will doze off.
If you have a job that requires accurate movements are accurate thinking,
you'll probably make no more mistakes than you usually do.
So let's say,
Hey,
if you stay up for 24 hours and still be good to go all next day,
which I know you've done this at the muster or close to it,
right?
We've done like an hour sleep,
two hours say,
but yeah,
I've done it before.
Maybe for one day.
Yeah.
And like second day you kind of hit the rack realer.
Big Time.
Yeah.
Uh,
the second night you won't want to stay up,
but you may have to another March may necessarily the enemy man attack and it's
the second night and the second night is like the first,
but more difficult.
It's harder to keep active under your own power yet you can if your officers and
the enemy furnished the motivation.
You don't want to keep your mind on any topic very long.
Your thoughts and ideas will trail off into irrelevancies have.
You can possibly get a chance to relax.
You will and then you'll go to sleep.
You ought not to be on century duty,
but you may keep awake by walking or if you go off into an inattentive days
while you continue walking,
by this time you will probably getting quite irritable.
Little things provoke you and you may talk some nonsense.
Your anger does not last though.
You'd rather go to sleep the day after.
The second.
Sleepless night is better than the preceding sleepless night,
but you'll be irritable,
rambling and illogical and speech thought.
An inattentive more than usually sensitive to pain.
Your eyes itch.
You may begin to see double.
You can't sit down to read.
Your handwriting becomes bad in Pennsylvania dropped from your hand.
You may even begin to have a loose imagining events that do not really happen as
if you begun to dream while you are still awake.
You can still be spurred to your full mental powers in manual dexterity if the
stimulus is strong enough.
If your commander demands your attention,
if a shell comes over,
but the effect of these things doesn't last as long as it would normally.
Pretty soon you're going back to where you were with the most important thing in
your world is to need the need to shut your eyes and go to sleep.
Wounded soldiers coming out of combat after many days and nights of continuing
continuous fighting's fighting maybe so terribly in need of sleep,
that even the severe pain of wounds has not keep them from going sound asleep as
soon as they are allowed to lie down and aesthetics can be dispensed with.
So there you go,
there's your,
there's your second day,
and now you're into your second day of the second full day without sleep.
How long can you go without sleep?
You can manage a third night without sleep and maybe a fourth with all the
symptoms getting worse with attention,
harder and harder to command with more activity necessary to keep you awake.
A psychologist wants,
kept himself awake for four whole days,
spurred only on by scientific motive for seeing what would happen next with dose
doses of a stimulant.
Ben's Adriene,
which is like an amphetamine which I had to look up to help.
He may actually,
he actually kept himself awake for eight whole days and seven nights.
There was a man once who believed that sleep was a bad habit which ought to and
could be overcome.
He was given a watchman's clock on which to record every 10 minutes.
The fact that he was awake,
he stayed awake almost continuously for nine and a half days missing only 31 out
of 1,380 recordings of the 10 minute intervals.
Of course,
he got some other cat naps during the 10 minute intervals.
As time wore on,
he became dazed.
He could keep appointments at the wrong time or in the wrong place or both.
He got so he could so that he was not always sure where he was.
At the end of the time,
he was beginning to have hallucinations and delusions of persecution and had
become so cantankerous that the experiment had to be stopped.
It just turned into so you just got so angry.
It just had to shut it down like it wasn't like he was going to die.
He was just real mad at everyone like,
well,
we can't take this anymore,
so that's pretty accurate.
Going back to the book,
sleep soon restores the sleepy man or animal.
The men who stay awake for two or three days are generally in pretty good shape
after a 12 hour sleep and show no effects at all after two or three normal
nights.
That's totally true.
You can get yourself back to normal real quick.
The whole trouble and sleeplessness is with attention and thus higher levels of
the brain which are necessary for attention.
The soldier who loses sleep is becoming an,
is becoming inefficient because he can no longer keep his mind on the job,
on any job except the one job of getting relaxation,
closed eyes and sleep.
He can be stimulated into attention by activity by a foretaste of command by,
but the effect of the spur last less and less as time,
less and less time as he gets sleepier.
When spurred,
he can do almost any simple task as about as well as usual,
unless it is a task that requires attention,
alertness,
and judgement.
Then he begins to fail being frustrated by not being allowed to sleep.
He becomes irritable,
belligerent,
and perhaps even unmanageable.
His morale goes down.
He's no longer a good comrade,
but his recovery will be rapid.
Give him sleep,
which is all he wants,
and pretty soon he'll be back.
His old competent,
friendly alerts self.
That's all right in an emergency.
But ordinarily soldiers should have enough sleep.
They need to be alert whether for study or combat weather driving a truck in
America or firing an anti tank gun in Africa or Europe.
Enough regular sleep from taps to first call should be the rule,
okay?
Except when the enemy decrees.
Otherwise there is no rule about the amount of sleep that young adults must
have.
Some get cranky and irritable when cut down from seven hours a night to five
others do not.
The unit with high morale can do with less sleep,
but sleepy men tend to have low morale.
Okay.
These two forces work against each other.
There is also,
there are also no rigid rules about the details of sleep.
No rules that apply to everyone alike.
So,
and,
and actually it's interesting because I'm here right now on a very minimal
amount of sleep.
I had a meet,
I had to fly to DC,
I had a meeting in DC.
It went late
and when I got done with the meeting,
got back to my hotel at midnight.
Yeah.
I had to prep this podcast.
I was on west coast time,
so I was like,
well it's only 10 o'clock or whatever,
nine o'clock so I just stayed awake.
My car pickup was it three?
I probably slept 40 minutes
and then we'll,
but then I did sleep on the plane flying back from the east coast out to here.
I got at least probably three hours of sleep.
They're uncomfortable or not.
Is that even sleep?
We don't know what does that count as?
Yeah.
And
okay.
Not Try not,
don't have much sleep right now.
We do a pretty good,
yeah,
it doesn't matter.
We'll be,
you know when people,
people call you can't perform.
I don't,
I don't know.
And people freak out and say you cannot,
there's no way you can perform as well when you're sleeping.
If you don't have enough sleep.
It's like,
Bro,
I get it.
Hey,
I'm not anti sleep.
If you need to sleep,
man,
sleep as much as you can sleep as much as you can.
See eight hours a day sleep,
10 hours date.
I don't care.
I'm not against you.
I don't hold it against you.
But there's things,
number one,
if you have a lot of things that you need to do and you spend a lot of time in
bed,
the things that you need to do aren't going to happen.
So you may need to get out of bed and get things to happen.
And number two,
I don't even,
I have horrible feeling if I sleep a lot.
Yeah.
Not,
not just,
okay.
I feel bad because I missed on doing some stuff that I'd probably needed to do.
Also,
I don't feel more rested.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I don't feel more rested if I sleep eight hours,
I feel sometimes it worse.
So,
yeah.
And he essentially said everyone's different.
Yes.
A hundred percent complete opposite.
I feel way more rested.
It's even seven hours.
I'm good.
Six hours is,
I'm fine.
Six hours,
two days in a row,
I'm not.
That's when those symptoms start to creep in.
Seven hours every single day.
Fine.
Eight hours.
I feel like a booth,
like I'm,
yeah,
nine hours.
I don't know if I would could go nine hours more than one or two nights in a
row.
Like just physically.
I just pick up whatever boy I could do the night hours and night,
like saw all it,
all it salad.
I'll have to try some something out off to try it out and see if I feel more
soft
live
for you.
You know?
Um,
like you said,
people will say,
hey,
you,
there's no way you can perform at your,
at your highest if you're sleep deprived or whatever.
Whatever I would imagine.
Just like,
cause you know how to say in here that everyone's different.
Like your optimum versus your subtle optimum mum might be like super small mom,
you know,
where you know,
you feel a little teeny tiny effects but your output or the results of your
output or whatever are pretty similar.
They're almost an pretty much unnoticeable even though you could have done a
little bit better with more sleep kind of thing.
But you know,
just like,
and then opposed to me where man I go five hours of sleep.
The difference between six hours of sleep and five of the sleep for me is like,
I feel like a completely different person like there.
Yeah.
Aw Man.
There was one time it was like,
I remember,
cause I was talking to [inaudible] so it was a time when life was in town.
I got like very hardly any hours asleep.
And I remember talking to him and thinking per leaf Vincam thinks I'm stupid or
just cause I didn't even really make sense.
I mean I don't know if he noticed it but I noticed it.
But then yeah,
if they got like six or seven or whatever's cool.
Well for everyone that freaks out.
I'm not saying don't save sleep,
sleep a bunch.
Sleep all you want.
That's fine.
You don't sound very confident or you don't sound very like,
well it's probably because
I don't,
cause you only got three hours of sleep.
Yeah,
you're irritable.
You're here in the morning because
I get that you should sleep.
But I think people take advantage of it real quick.
That makes any,
they start just getting
into the,
you know,
I am just going to sleep all the time.
It's like when someone says dark chocolate's good for you.
You don't know say chocolate cake.
Yeah.
And then it's like,
well does that include dark chocolate cake?
Is that include dark chocolate,
triple fudge ice cream?
Cause the dark chocolate is good for you.
So I'm in the game,
so sleep is good for me,
so I'm not getting out of bed.
So,
but whatever,
I encourage people to sleep and I,
it's not,
the other thing is that it's crazy.
It's,
it's not like I don't sleep.
I sleep,
I sleep almost every day.
You know what I mean?
It's good.
I go almost every day.
I sleep.
No,
I see.
Just about every day I go to bed at 01030111130 somewhere in there.
I wake up at four 30 maybe for 20 maybe four 32 but that's a lot of sleep.
You know,
that's between five and six hours every day.
Yeah.
I mean it guests for your standard,
but two people freaking out,
so no reason.
Well,
you know what I mean?
For people who are sleep deprived and they do have differences,
which very much I do know,
I do know this for a fact.
When I have less sleep,
I'm more emotional.
Oh yeah.
And,
and you know what?
I actually,
it actually is helpful for me.
Oh Dang.
Oh yeah.
Like I like to be sleep deprived to somewhat,
I don't session and say say I like to sleep a little bit less because it's more,
it makes more,
it makes my life a little bit more on edge,
which I like.
Actually what's funny is you said that one time when you were like,
I like a little bit of Sleep Dep.
That was weird when you told me.
I was like,
I guess I see what you're saying cause it Kinda,
it's almost like a comfort thing,
right?
Like if you're too comfortable,
like you might be more inclined to relax almost kinda idea even though,
I mean I can't really get down with it because the more rested I am the more
happier I'm going to feel.
Like you say emotional and in the book it's an irritable right there.
I think it's the same thing with irritable,
like to kind of like I'm irritable with like stuff,
not even inanimate stuff like the my,
my phone isn't connected to my Bluetooth in my car quick enough.
I'm like what still is wrong with this thing in my head,
you know,
that kind of stuff even.
But then if I'm rested pat,
no,
no factor.
Maybe it won't work at all.
I don't care if I had to see,
I like that little bit of edge cause part of it is because things like that
never bothered me.
So it was or whatever my phone didn't conduct to.
So you're kind of dead.
Yeah,
I'd rather bring it back to life.
A little bit of anger,
irritability,
make it good.
Anyways,
so that's where I want to stop for this podcast about this book and on the next
book,
and actually this is like the warm up and I think the second half of the book
is,
is even better.
It's when it gets into the morale,
it's when it gets into leadership,
it's when it gets into the psychological warfare office and defense.
And so we'll pick that up on the next podcast.
I want to do one more little passage from this book here.
It's a shorter passage,
but it's just,
uh,
again,
just to,
just a reminder of what,
what war is going back to and we go on by,
we'll bird,
here we go.
We found the platoon and hardly recognized it.
The sergeant was there and Mcdonald's,
but the rest were strangers.
They told me that the 73rd of the fourth division had been so caught up that
they had been withdrawn and the 85th Nova Scotia highlanders had taken their
place.
The remnant of the 73rd had been divided between us and the 13th I got
McDonald's the one side and ask questions.
Okay.
It was far worse than I thought.
Yeah.
The 42nd had gone straight through to their objective.
Despite the sleet,
the snow and mud and confusion had driven back all opposition and sees their
objective,
but on their left,
the fourth division had been held up and a flanking fire had taken a heavy toll.
Freddie was gone.
He had predict.
He had predicted truly a big shell had landed beside him killing him and burying
him.
Charlie had fallen in the first rush riddled with bullets.
Joe,
the [inaudible] policemen had fought through to the objective and had been
killed by a sniper on the flank.
One shell had wiped out Stevenson thorough and Roy as they grouped by a captured
gun.
Okay.
Mcmillan had been shot in the stomach and it died after waiting hours in a
trench.
Billy,
the complainer had fallen as he had charged a machine gun keeping on until he
was almost within reach of the gunners.
Little Gilroy had been killed and Westcott smelly had been wounded,
huggy.
The sergeant had been defied and it had been wounded at the same time and had
been taken away together.
Big Herman was missing.
They load co located his body.
A month later that morning you'd shaken hands with Freddy,
said goodbye to him and then we had,
when he had got going,
had run a muck.
He was found almost at the bottom of the ridge near a battery position with
eight dead Germans about him.
Four of them killed by bad debt
in the other besides Tommy slim and Joe had survived and Irin Sam and big Glenn
and Eddie and Mickey and Jerry.
They sat in the dug out that night after a hard day of rebuilding roads,
each man's suffering from bodily fatigue and crawling with vermin and the clam,
he chill of mud.
Kate clothing,
their faces,
brooding,
enigmatic,
even Mickey's curiously odd,
only their eyes moving.
They would not talk about the fighting and seemed utterly worn.
Six months ago,
we had marched eagerly bravely are tin hats askew and with a cheeky retort for
every comment,
Heidi,
whatever secret apprehensions we had,
not knowing the heavy,
ominous silence that follows the burst of big shells and the cries of the
wounded not knowing what it is to scrape a hasty grave at night.
And there Barry,
a man who has worked with you and slept with you since you enlisted.
Clearly,
war is hell.
It's a physical and it is a psychological hill.
And the more we know about it,
the more we should understand that war is to be avoided as much as humanly
possible.
But it also teaches us how strong we as human beings can be.
What we can overcome.
It teaches us the importance of training,
the importance of preparation,
the importance of will not only the will to win in war,
but the will to carry on and to win
in life.
And we all have that power.
Yeah,
we just need to find it.
Okay.
And to win.
And I think that's all I've got tonight.
So Echo Charles.
Speaking of
winning,
I know we are sort of trying to be on the path of winning mentally,
physically,
psychologically in life and on the mats.
Okay.
And I know that's sort of the thing we're doing here,
the movement.
Sure.
And I know you have some recommendations for that.
Yes.
Might be helpful.
They will be helpful actually.
Nice.
What do you got?
I have,
well,
we're on the path,
right?
We got that week war.
Life is war.
We're at
war.
All out war.
All out war on that war.
No,
total war.
Podo work.
That's what we're in.
Yes.
Total war.
So we'd be in that total war.
There's little battles,
right?
So I think people are not going to like that.
What life is war.
But it's so true.
Yeah,
I mean it,
I mean if you start looking at your life like it's war,
it's going to make you better.
Yet,
if you look at every day as a war on multiple fronts,
you know that you have to fight where victory is the only choice.
You're going to have a better life actually.
It's really,
yeah,
it's really good.
Even for someone who look,
I get it.
The word war might trigger some people.
It's just like the word fight might trigger some people,
but you could say life is a fight.
It's always a fight,
not against people.
My suspicion is the amount of people listening to this podcast that are
triggered by the word to war or fight is zero.
Zero.
Yes,
I agree with you.
That's my suspicion.
I could be wrong,
but they're severely triggered at this point if that's where they're at.
That's the only thing we talk about is fighting in war.
Yes.
I think you're right.
I believe you are right.
Making sure so within the all out war there's little battles,
right,
and in those battles,
one of those battles is the Jujitsu.
When you do this,
you're going to need a g and a rash guard just to begin.
That's why I think so.
Actually technically you could wear basketball shorts and a tank top.
You could not recommend and I recommend,
especially the basketball shorts.
Yeah.
They will be pulled down,
pull down,
pulled up,
caught on people's toes.
Sometimes just not a good plan.
Not as good as like,
yeah,
maybe some board shorts.
They don't.
As far as,
yeah.
Nonetheless,
this is where you can get these things from origin,
origin,
main.com that's where you go get a rash guard,
get a geat best game in the world.
Factually,
by the way,
also happens to be made in America.
Are they the best because they're made in America?
Maybe,
maybe not,
but those are two separate either way.
Reminded,
Oh yeah,
best games in the world.
Many different options there.
Also,
grass cards,
like I said,
also joggers.
Yeah,
like I said before,
but yeah,
a lot of clothes.
Apparel.
We'll say.
What you're missing is jeans.
Yes,
there are genes.
Wait,
can we get genes now?
We should be getting jeans now.
I know I have origin jeans.
I know I'm in a little bit of a preferred scenario.
I know people.
Yeah,
so I was going to say,
wait,
if we can all get jeans now that's interesting because I didn't get any.
Yeah,
well,
the genes are being made at this time,
so they're available.
We'll denim,
American denim,
American made best jeans ever obviously.
And yeah,
check 'em out or do you mean.com also supplements best kind of supplements.
So I've can't come to the conclusion that the harsh conclusion and that exercise
generally speaking is probably the best thing you can do for yourself.
Agree.
Generally speaking,
I'm not saying there's no exceptions,
I'm not saying that.
And you're not saying that throw everything else into the dumpster.
Correct?
Yes.
So when,
when it comes to supplements,
okay,
well,
so what is,
what's the best kind of supplements to take then?
If we understand that exercise is the best thing you can do for yourself,
what kind of supplements?
Is it like muscle building supplements or is it,
this is what I'm asking myself as I'm driving.
Cause they drive sometimes or is it the kind of supplement that allows you to
stay able to exercise at full capacity longer?
Probably those,
right?
I know what you think.
Yeah.
Mozhan you like to joint warfare Krill oil.
Yes sir.
You liked the discipline,
right?
Because,
and I say this because it's not selfish.
It's not just intuitive.
You think supplements to give my body bigger or whatever.
Stronger.
But what if you do want to get more yoke to let's say,
how would you get some of that mold?
Like you said,
we don't throw everything else into the dumpster.
I'm just saying this is [inaudible] road and I eating whatever and when I go on
the road I go on a trip,
I eat.
I usually really good cause I go on a steak restaurants and I get rib eyes.
Yes sir.
And no matter what,
when I come home I want to have more.
Yeah.
Cause I have that mint chocolate chip Monck cause it's like a dessert.
It is a disease.
Without the guilt we actually crap.
Yeah that yes.
Literally good for you.
How can you get to dessert?
That's actually good for you.
I'll tell you how you got to origin main.com you give them.
Okay.
If you've got kids instead of feeding kids junk,
that's horrible for them.
You get them some warrior kid milk,
you will have kids that want to drink something that's awesome for them.
Yup.
And by then it's a meal by the way.
They will be stoked to get your sick kids.
Some warrior kid milk.
Tasty people would ask him about when the strawberry adult Moke is coming out.
I told me,
I told the little,
do not mess this up.
I'm like the strawberry kids.
Mark is APIC.
It's epic.
Yeah.
I said if you mess up and the,
and the adult strawberry milk is an APP,
beck,
we're going to have an issue.
That's a problem.
Be Little's on the case.
Yeah.
Well he's on the case yet.
It's true.
Also,
Jack was the store.
It's called Jocko store,
so go to juggle store.com this is where you can get shirts,
hoodies,
rap,
more rash guards,
all representative of this path that we're on.
We're on the path certainly,
and we're going to stay on the path where you stay on the path until the path
path ends.
And guess what?
The little answer to that little riddle about doesn't it?
So,
but if you want to represent Jocko,
store.com got some new stuff on there.
By the way,
we're a little new design of the hoodies,
you know,
really like that one nonetheless.
Hey look,
go check it out.
If you like something or something.
Triggers.
Stickers are some,
uh,
yeah,
but there's bumper stickers on there.
This patches on there.
There's more.
I just designed a new rash guard.
It's not like totally new with a new rash guard sent it to Pete.
We're getting it done and should be there and a,
you know,
within the week.
Um,
also I know week to you talk a lot of trash to me about lightweight hoodies.
We're going to do a lightweight Hoodie,
100% despite pipe.
Okay.
Jocko unapproved.
But when you see it,
it's going to be approved anyway.
If you like something gets on.
If I was going to wear a lightweight Hoodie,
I would just wear a tee shirt,
bro.
Yeah,
I did it.
But some of us,
you know,
we liked that there's like this little intermediary pose,
a situation where it's not hot,
it's cold,
but it's not cold cold.
You don't like when the wind sort of blows consistently and you're like,
you know,
I couldn't think we by the grace of decentralized command that this is
happening.
Yes.
Because despite spite what you're saying to me,
yes.
A medium or whatever.
You said a light weight hoodie makes no logical sense to me as a human.
You know,
that's one of the many differences between me and you can.
I think that there are a lot of people out there who support me on this
decision,
which is why we will track and see if anyone buys lightweight.
Just go into the numbers.
Okay.
I understand.
Also,
there's women's stuff.
Present them to the people.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well,
there it is.
Yeah.
Anyway,
Jocko,
store.com there's some women's stuff on there.
Then there's cool stuff.
You've liked something,
get something.
It's a good way to represent for sure.
Also,
Jocko white tea,
if you want to deadlift 8,000 pounds if you're not already.
Okay.
This is the reason or one of the reasons,
unless you're already a tea drinker,
even if you're not a teacher,
because I wasn't teaching anchor Nigerian Jocko White Tea,
so I am a teacher in cartel.
Technically.
This is the original.
This is like the first thing.
What?
I'm going to make something,
I'm going to make this tea.
Oh,
the university is the front of the product.
It some on the way over here.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
man.
If you kind of guess I was a little bit chilly.
I wanted some warm tea.
I could have used a little lightweight.
Anyway,
it's interesting how all these products is all stuff that you use.
So you're like,
you're like walking,
not walking,
but you're just sorta existing.
You're like,
hmm.
Instead of like,
you know,
getting this stuff.
Let me just make it so,
and it turns out you make all your own stuff.
Well,
the thing is
if you're going to,
I'm picky.
That's my problem.
I'm picky about what I like and what I don't like.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I'm straight forward,
but I'm picky.
I want this specific thing a specific way and you can't buy what I want or you
couldn't,
you couldn't buy what I want now.
You can just do what I want.
It's just like everything,
like the g,
like victory,
MMA and fitness,
our gym.
Why is that?
Why does it exist?
Because we want it to have the way we want things to be.
You can't just,
you can't go to someone else's gym and expect it to be the way you want it.
You can't buy some supplement off the shelf and expect it to taste the way you
want it to taste.
It's going to taste the way some random person in some other area,
you wanted it to taste.
They don't know what tastes good.
Yeah.
Well,
and they're going to take,
once they figure they had to put in the,
they're just trying to make the maximum profit margin so they're putting
feelers,
whatever.
So anyways,
make totally mix.
If you're going to make something then if you have to,
you,
if you want to use something,
why not make it the way you want it?
Origin genes,
by the way.
Same thing the way I want them to be made to way Pete likes all made,
you know,
in America.
So anyways,
yeah.
That's how we ended up doing this stuff.
Cool.
Boom.
Yeah.
Good.
I'm glad you did by the way.
Oh,
and uh,
there's some people we joked about subscribing to the podcast.
I saw some comments that people didn't,
hadn't subscribed the podcast until the last show.
This dude was like,
I listened to 163 episodes and I never subscribed to the podcast until you said
and joked about who would listen to 163 episodes and not subscribe to the
podcast.
And he said that was me.
So there might be one other person out there that hasn't subscribed to the
podcast or hasn't subscribed to the youtube channel or hasn't subscribed to the
warrior kid podcast.
So if you haven't subscribed to those things do so wait,
what do you mean you stand corrected?
You're the one that always says like there might be someone that's an,
I didn't believe you.
I think,
I don't know if I'd ever say for subscribing,
but it was yes,
I always said or feel that it seems obvious.
Yes to subscribe,
subscribe.
And I always thought that that was dumb and I thought to myself who could listen
to this podcast over and over get an,
not subscribed to it,
but that rubbed off on me and I started to feel that way.
In fact,
cause right now I'm trying to search my feelings and I do feel that way.
Like why are you telling people to subscribe?
So we don't need to say this anymore.
But now what I'm saying is we got reports back from the field of people that
didn't subscribe yet.
162 podcast deep,
huh?
And now we're 164 podcasts.
If you have them subscribe to the podcast subscribers.
If you check out the youtube channel,
by the way,
the youtube channel echoes videos are on there.
He's real proud of him.
He puts little things exploding.
Some people think it's too much.
Well,
some people think it's sometimes they're,
sometimes they're right in there.
It's a dichotomy.
You gotta balance that iconomy no,
I have no effects.
Too many effects.
There's varying levels of appropriateness with affects.
So at some point I want you to purposely make a video that's completely,
you take whatever I've said on this podcast that's over the top anyways,
and then just make the most over the top video.
That is a good,
I remember one time I said,
don't sleep,
eat steak,
train her or something like that.
That's what,
that's what the video should it be about that?
Just guys with broken legs crawling out on the mat with a steak hanging out of
their mouth,
you know,
like that kind of thing over the top.
Everything exploding a fire because lot of times your explosion is don't have
fire.
A lot of times they're just smoking more,
more like smoking dust.
You keep it dark.
Explosions more just like dis rent,
like various levels of destruction.
So check that out.
Check out the warrior kids soap,
Irish oaks,
ranch.com young eight and making or your kid's soap
checkout,
psychological warfare,
little tidbits of information to help you overcome momentary weakness.
I'll tell you how to do it.
It's not real complicated,
but it is effective.
Check Amazon music to swear you can get it.
And I turned to you by MP three that's what's called psychological warfare.
It's a good one.
Very much.
Also,
you want to subscribe to the warrior kid podcast.
I said that.
I'm glad you're emphasizing it though.
Well.
Yeah,
I thought you didn't say that.
Okay.
I think I missed them.
That's nice nonetheless.
Yeah.
It's a good one.
That's a good one for you and the kids,
both of you guys.
Cause they're,
they're,
they're good lessons,
but they're super basic.
Just like this.
Just like this book man.
Very much.
So.
Also on it,
on it.com.
Go there slash Jack.
Go on [inaudible] dot com slash travel this is where you can get kettlebells,
add to your home gym,
add to your capability.
Rings.
Add to that.
Keep me.
But I just got some,
uh,
the storm trooper on Star Wars.
Straight up pop right.
Don't hate on that Russ third.
They're dope.
None the less.
We were a lot of good stuff on there.
Good fitness stuff.
Do you hear of storm troopers?
Do you actually think of like bad ass?
Yeah,
cause I always think of them as just things that get shot all up.
And that is true.
That is true.
But humans,
yeah,
there are people,
they're troopers actually,
I think they're clones of people.
So this,
that's why they're just fodder.
They just get killed by laser beams all the time in the movie.
Yes,
but when you see a storm trooper kettle bell,
it's pretty cool.
And there's a Darth Vader one too.
There's an iron man one and there's a,
the Boba Fett guy wouldn't jangle fed or both of them,
I don't know.
They wear the same helmet.
So nonetheless related there.
One is where the Clune came from.
If I'm not mistaken,
I don't know.
I might've got my star wars mythology mixed up,
but nonetheless they are kettle bells now on.
It makes them end their dope.
A lot of cool stuff on there.
On it Dotcom.
Slash Jocko.
We got Mickey in the dragons book that's available right now for every kid that
you know,
get a Mike in the dragons way the warrior kid
and weigh the warrior kid to Mark's mission.
Those are books to show your kid how to be on the path.
And now we have combing warrior kid three which now has a sub title and the
subtitle is where there's a will.
So he has to dig deep in this book learns a little bit about digging deep.
He also learns a little bit about humility.
He learns about ego for the first time.
His Ego starts getting involved.
So check out those books that I will let you know when where your kid three is
available for preorder,
which we're going to be a little bit more efficient at this time when we do
preorders so we don't get into the Mike and the dragon situation where people
have to wait a little extra time to get the book when it comes out.
So book for you,
I'll let you know when that's ready.
The field manual discipline equals freedom field manual available right now.
I was with a buddy of mine that's a in the finance world and has,
you know,
one of those,
I guess it'd be a stereotypical office of the finance,
the investment bankers,
you know,
I'm talking about everything's all clean and white,
New York City type thing.
And he showed me a picture in there as you walk in this beautiful clean office
entryway.
It's not even an office.
It's like a thing for Yay.
Yeah,
yeah.
One of those.
And there's a white table.
It is a big white table.
You know,
it was probably eight by eight.
There's one book by itself,
the field manual,
and he says,
and he says his,
his uh,
front office girl the other day,
said,
everyone that comes in looks at that book and says,
what is this?
Where does come from?
Where did you get this?
Every single person who makes a comment.
So that's the field manual.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
Get it for anyone that needs to little help being on the path and you who needs
helping on the path.
Everybody.
Extreme ownership.
First Book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin leadership lessons from the
battlefield.
And then we wrote the dichotomy of leadership,
which gives some guidance on how to be more balanced as a leader.
Because if you get out of balance as a leader and you extreme in one
direction or the other in a multitude of various dichotomies,
you will rip your team apart,
which is not good.
So dichotomy of leadership.
Get that one.
We also got Ashkelon Front,
which is our leadership consultancy.
And that's what we do is we solve problems through leadership.
It's me.
It's Leif Babin JP to now Dave Berg,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike's Rally,
Mike by Ima,
go to echelon front.com.
If you want us to come and work with your company,
get your leadership aligned and get your entire organization on the path to
victory.
Hit us up.
We have the muster,
which is our leadership event,
2019 we're doing it May 23rd and 24th in Chicago.
Wouldn't do in September 19th and 20th in Denver.
And we're doing December 4th and fifth in Sydney,
Australia.
Are you going to Australia with us?
Yes.
Okay.
So that's what's happening.
Every event that we've done has sold out.
And when I say sold out,
I mean were personal friends of mine are saying,
hey,
it's a little late,
but can you just,
ah,
just I just need three seats and you know,
from me.
And uh,
my girlfriend and my buddy were going to go and I'm like,
actually,
no,
I can't,
there's no more seats and the fire code will not allow any more human beings in
there.
So these all are going to sell out.
There'll be no
alibis sick like well in the military told safe rounds or alibis meaning like I
got an extra round.
Hey just one,
one more like no,
it's not going to happen.
So,
and don't get mad if that does happen.
You know,
Oh joke was you know,
can help you.
Uh,
we have to talk to the fire Marshalls.
So if you want to come sign up early extreme ownership.com I'll tell you what
the Australia one is going to be,
it's going to sell out quick because I think there's 450 seats.
That is not a lot.
And when I did a book signing up in Brizzy of in Brisbane,
Australia,
Brisbane,
there was a ton of people there that flew to Brisbane to,
to hang out for five minutes,
you know,
get a book signed.
So that one in Sydney is going to be sold out quick.
So jump on there if you want to come down,
if you're a trooper in the game,
come to the muster extreme ownership.com e f online now active,
what is it?
It's interactive leadership training online.
It actually puts you into scenarios that you have to figure out that you have to
make decisions,
combat scenarios,
business scenarios,
role playing scenarios,
dealing with people.
It's it's awesome training.
It will really ingrain the principles of extreme ownership,
the laws of combat,
the dichotomy of leadership.
It will ingrain them into you.
It'll make you better leader.
That is f online.com whether you're a company that wants to use it as enterprise
service,
are you just an individual that wants to get in the game deeper?
Go to [inaudible] dot com and we also have e f Overwatch where we're taking
proven combat leaders from special operations and combat aviation communities
and we're putting them into businesses that need experienced proven leaders.
Go to e f overwatch.com if you're on either side of that calculation,
whether you're a vet that needs work or whether you're a company that needs
leaders,
let us know.
F overwatch.com and if you want to talk to us or you want to share a good book
with us,
like a,
somebody shared the psychology for the fighting man with me on the interwebs,
that's where we can be found on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on Facebook.
Echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And of course thanks to all of those who serve our military personnel,
police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT is correctional officer's border patrol,
all first responders,
all of you that put on a uniform and protect us from evil in the world.
We can only do what we do because you do what you do.
So fake you
and to everyone else out there that is listening,
remember to train hard,
do your best to prepare,
stay in the fight.
And even though you might not feel like it,
sometimes you can drive on.
Yeah,
you can push through.
You can deal with unimaginable adversity
as long as you keep getting up every day moving forward and getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.